to
your role as a judge and as a potential
supreme court justice and they're also
getting to know you personally
and we've had the opportunity to hear a
bit about your family
your background
i think it's also appropriate that the
american public hear a bit more about
your brother's story
as i understand it
served
the baltimore police department
served in the u.s army
before we turn to matters of law will
you please help introduce yourself and
your family to the american public as
you seek this lifetime appointment
tell us a bit about him and his story
thank you senator um
my brother followed in a long tradition
in my family of public service
it was a core family value
um my parents were both public servants
and
um my mothers two of my mother's
brothers were career law enforcement
and my brother and i are almost a decade
apart in age and
he i think
looked up to my uncles
who
were often around in their uniforms
keeping their weapons away from the kids
by putting them up on high shelves and
we um we looked up to them and we
understood
through their service
what it meant to give back to your
community
my brother went to college uh
historically black college howard
university here in washington dc
um after growing up in miami
and uh decided to
follow my um follow in my uncle's
footsteps
he could have done
many things coming out of college with a
college degree but decided he wanted to
be
a police officer and went
to baltimore
which as many of you know
struggles like many cities with
with areas that are
have a lot of crime and
it was a very
it was a very stressful period for us as
a family because as proud as we are of
his service as much as we know it's
important
law enforcement is a dangerous
profession and
as family members you worry
when you don't get the phone call when
you haven't heard for a couple of days
when you hear about things in the news
in the community you worry
and so
i grew up um with family members who put
their lives on the line i understand
the need for law enforcement the
importance of
having people who are willing to do that
important work the importance of holding
people accountable
for their criminal behavior
um i also
as a lawyer and a citizen
believe very strongly in our
constitution
and the rights that make us free
and what that means to me
is an understanding that although we
need accountability although there is
crime we also
have a society
that
ensures that people who have been
accused of criminal behavior are treated
fairly
that is what our constitution requires
that is what makes our system so
exceptional
my brother understood that as part of
his work and he also
served
in the military he also decided as many
people did to defend our country after 9
11 that he would
go into the army
and i remember when he made that
decision
he had a college degree he could have
been an officer right away he could have
been a type of military officer that
didn't have to actually be on the
battlefield and i remember saying are
you going to do something with you know
radio signals are you going to be behind
the scenes and he said no no i'm going
to be infantry boots on the ground
he said i believe strongly
in the protection of our country and if
i'm going to be leading i'm going to be
out front
that's the kind of person my brother is
it's the kind of service that our family
provides and for me what that meant
was
an understanding
that to defend our country and its
values
we also needed to make sure
that
when we responded as a country to the
terrible attacks on 9 11
we were upholding our constitutional
values that we weren't allowing the
terrorists to win
by
changing who we are
and so i joined with many lawyers
during that time who were helping the
courts figure out
the limits of executive authority
consistent with what the framers have
told us is important
the limitations on government
i worked to
protect our country my brother worked on
the front lines and it was all because
public service is important to us
thank you judge jackson
let's talk a bit about limitations on
power
our constitution
is a document that renounces monarchism
and instead establishes a
republic
you in uh
opinion
that has been widely cited
made the observation that presidents are
not kings
what does that mean and
what are some of the most important
bulwarks in our constitutional system
against the abuse of executive power
against tyranny
thank you senator
our constitutional
scheme the design of our government
is
erected to prevent
tyranny
the framers decided
after experiencing monarchy tyranny and
the like
that they were going to create a
government that would split the powers
of a monarch
in several different ways one was
federalism it was vertical they would
split the powers between the federal
government and states
another was to prevent the federal
government from itself becoming too
powerful
from having all of
the authorities from having legislative
executive and judicial authority
concentrated in one place
so
the constitution
in its design
puts the legislative authority in
article one and gives it to the congress
the power to make laws
it puts the executive authority in
article two and gives it to the
president
the power to execute the laws and it
puts the judicial authority the power to
interpret the laws in article 3 and
gives it to the court
the separation of powers is crucial
to liberty it is what our
country is founded on and it's important
as consistent with my judicial
methodology
for each branch
to operate within their own sphere
that means for me that judges can't
make law judges shouldn't be policy
makers that's a part of our
constitutional design and it prevents
our government from being too powerful
and
encroaching on individual liberty
thank you judge i i mentioned in my
opening remarks that the court
has played a vital role
constrained
within its proper constitutional
boundaries
in the national process of making
america in real life
what america is in text
and reflecting on your experience as a
public defender
a vital role in our justice system
let's talk a little bit about the sixth
amendment
and the role that the court played in
ensuring that the sixth amendment is
real in practice
in the gideon v wainwright decision can
you
help all those who are tuned in right
now to reflect upon that decision what
it means what it says about the role of
the court
yes senator um prior to gideon versus
wainwright
people who could not afford lawyers
were not entitled to lawyers under our
system so a person
could be accused by the government of
criminal behavior and
would have to
fend for themselves in court they would
have to make their own arguments
someone who is not a lawyer would
still be responsible
for defending him or herself in front of
a judge if the government brought
charges
earl gideon
was a
criminal defendant from florida my home
state
who
had a handwritten petition
he complained that it wasn't fair under
our constitutional scheme that protects
and requires people to be tried
he said i need help i'm not a lawyer i
can't make these arguments
i think
it's important
for
uh uh the protection of liberty
to ensure that people are able to have
counsel
and that handwritten
petition made its way to the supreme
court
and the justices read it
and they determined to take his case and
in the end decided
that the protections of the sixth
amendment the right to trial
includes the right to appointed counsel
so that everybody who is con
accused of criminal behavior now has the
right
to an attorney
and that's
very important i mean one of the things
that i see or saw as a trial judge
is that it was crucial
for our justice system to have
representation
from both sides
it was the only way that a judge it is
the only way that a judge can really
make
fair determinations
and in cases you know we've heard a lot
about my criminal cases in every case
i'm getting as a judge
arguments from the prosecution i'm
getting arguments from the defense
counsel i'm getting arguments or
statements from probation in these
criminal cases and the work of a judge
is to look at the facts and
circumstances hear the arguments of the
parties apply the law and make a fair
determination and so having lawyers for
criminal defendants aids in that process
and benefits us all in our criminal
justice system
i would just take the opportunity to
note at this time judge jackson that it
so happens that the southern district of
georgia is one of just three
federal districts without a federal
defender's office and i've offered
legislation to establish one and i'll be
seeking support from my republican
colleagues to try to make that
bipartisan to ensure there is
access to council for defendants
in my state
let's talk a bit about the first
amendment
freedoms of speech
publication
assembly
there's a well-known supreme court case
brandenburg the ohio which establishes a
certain test to ensure that the
government is
constrained
in any effort
that may be made to
punish speech
and the
impulse to censorship
is something that can emerge from time
to time across the ideological
and political spectrum
particularly in times of great
controversy or in times of
national security crisis
can you
please walk the committee and the
broader public watching now from all
across the country
through
that decision and how you will approach
these vital protections
for speech publication and assembly
should you be confirmed
thank you senator
freedom of speech
publication assembly
is in the first amendment of the
constitution it is
a core foundational protection
against censorship
it is important in our constitutional
scheme
that people be allowed to express
themselves that ideas be exchanged that
is the groundwork
for
a vigorous and vital democracy
there are
many tests many cases in the supreme
court's
jurisprudence
that
discuss various
disputes about
um circumstances in which the government
can
restrain or regulate
speech
and
that decision
um
establishes to a certain extent that
uh
if there is speech that is an incitement
to violence
that's one circumstance in which the
government might be able to prevent it
but other than that short of that
free speech is supposed to be allowed to
happen
and
there are again various tests and
circumstances that the court has applied
in deciding whether the government can
can regulate the content place and
manner of speech
but the general principle
is that our democracy is
thrives because the government is
restrained and cannot censor uh its
citizens
i think in the in the same spirit of
banks
with which i open these questions i also
want to just take a moment and recognize
the members of the press who are here
the reporters and photographers who
ensure that
these proceedings are truly accessible
to the public
and
ask you to describe your approach to
press freedom
um
the question of prior con a prior
restraint
has been litigated
um
a famous case in the context of the
pentagon papers
in the latter years of the vietnam war
i know i believe for all of us on this
committee we recognize the vital role of
press freedom
in ensuring the free exchange of ideas
access to truth and debate in our
democracy how will you approach
cases that implicate press freedom
thank you senator um this is another
area in which there is a
well-established case law
um
that
supports the freedom of the press to be
able to
write and report
um there there is a general obligation
of truth in terms of the press but also
a recognition
that sometimes um sometimes there may be
things that get published that aren't
exactly accurate and so the court in
new york times versus sullivan
determined a higher standard of
liability for press
things that are put out in the press
have to be knowingly
false there's an actual malice test
because the court
was balancing uh concerns about libel
people uh claiming that they have been
misrepresented in the press with the
need to allow the press to do their job
the the overall um understanding is that
press freedom
again is is one of the first amendment
freedoms that are undergird our
democracy something i just want to take
a moment and observe
judge jackson uh is you know and
uh this is my first such proceeding so
i'm grateful the chairman for
opening today's ceremonies at the end of
the deus but
um
something that i've studied and i'm
aware of is that there's been a range uh
over time
of
how willing nominees are
to
candidly and openly and forthrightly
discuss these core matters of
constitutional principle in proceedings
like this one and a tendency over time
to allow less and discuss less
a
more restrictive approach
and i want to thank you because
while you have prudently in disciplined
in a disciplined way
refrained from commenting
inappropriately on potential pending
case law you have been willing to engage
in a forthright and expansive discussion
of these vital principles um in a way
that i think stands out among some
recent nominees that's not a criticism
of any recent nominees it's an
observation about your performance and i
think that having an open and honest
uh and forthright dialogue about these
matters of national significance is part
of the vital role that these proceedings
serve
i want to turn now to
the fourth amendment
i want to discuss with you
the protections against unreasonable
search and seizure we discussed how the
constitution
was a renunciation of monarchism and
tyranny it establishes core
civil liberties
one of which is the protection against
unreasonable search and seizure how will
you approach fourth amendment case law
and can you
help those tuned in across the country
remind them of what for example the
principle of a reasonable expectation of
privacy means
in the context of supreme court
jurisprudence
thank you senator
the fourth amendment is one of the
amendments in the constitution
that
protects individual liberty by
limiting
what the government can do
with respect to criminal processes
it
restrains the government from engaging
in unreasonable searches and seizures
and the supreme court has developed
a series of tests and
ways of
evaluating whether any particular
act by an officer in a case
qualifies as an unreasonable search or a
seizure
let me just say that
this is the kind of area of
supreme court
and
judicial review
that is very fact specific
because
courts in order to stay in our
appropriate role
can't
make policy about
police behavior writ large
can't just sort of look out into the
universe and say we have a constitution
that says unreasonable searches and
seizures so let us tell you
all what that means that's not the way
that courts operate
under article 3 courts can only hear
individual cases and controversies and
decide them
so
every court including the supreme court
is looking at
unreasonable search and seizures in the
context of a particular dispute
where someone has
had something searched by an officer in
their house they've been seized
under a particular set of facts and they
claim in the context of a lawsuit
or in the context of defending
themselves
that there has been an unreasonable
search or seizure
and so the court
case by case by case
looks at the facts and circumstances and
decides
and
i would say that this is this is the
kind of analysis that takes into account
uh a number of things but one of the
things um in addition to understanding
the facts and circumstances is
understanding what is meant in the
constitution
by unreasonable search and seizure
there is case law
that
the supreme court has developed
that looks at whether or not something
is an unreasonable search and seizure in
part by analyzing whether there was a
reasonable expectation of privacy
uh in that
item
um in that area is there a reasonable
expectation of privacy in your house for
example if a police officer were to come
into your house
you you would not be able to claim
fourth amendment protection unless
says the supreme court there was a
reasonable expectation of privacy in
your house
and the supreme court has determined
whether there's a reasonable expectation
of privacy for example in your house
by looking at what areas were protected
at the time of the founding
when
the words unreasonable searches and
seizures were written into the
constitution
lo and behold something like your house
the court has determined there is a
reasonable expectation of privacy
because that's what those terms meant
back then
and so if a police officer were to come
without a warrant the court has said in
areas where there is a reasonable
expectation of privacy
that would be an unlawful search
this is an area where the emergence of
new technologies
makes it likely i believe that should
you be confirmed you will have to
consider
fourth amendment claims
in light of circumstances that couldn't
have been anticipated at the time of the
drafting of the constitution and indeed
constitutional interpretation has
already evolved over time
to adapt to the reality of new
technologies
from phone booths
a classic case in the late 1960s but
whether a closed phone booth door
demonstrates an expectation of privacy
to more recent case law involving
geolocation data
from cell phones
and i want to urge you should you be
confirmed
to remain vigilant
about how the emergence of new
technologies the way that they become
ubiquitous
in our lives the way that virtual spaces
are increasingly akin to physical spaces
will require the court to consider
very complex questions and to seek
technical advice
because these are
technologically complex questions what
is your view on how the court should
seek
such technical expertise
which may be with all due respect
beyond the training or experience of a
justice or their clerk
and
if for example one such method of
seeking advice is through amiki what's
the importance of understanding the
provenance and origin and funding source
of such briefs submitted to the court
this is a two-part question i want to
restate it the first is
again i want to urge you should you be
confirmed
as i'm confident you will
to
vigorously
defend the constitutional rights of
american citizens against unreasonable
search and seizure in the context of new
technologies i'd like to hear how you'll
approach seeking technical expertise to
inform that decision making and then a
question about the transparency
of briefs filed before the court
something that justice scalia noted in
some campaign finance case laws that
it's important for the public to know
who's funding electioneering
communications in the context of
political campaigns i think it's
important for the court to know who's
briefing them
what the motive and funding source of
such briefs might be could you please
with my remaining time and then i'll
yield and we'll have some more time
later to discuss war powers
could you please comment on those
matters those will be my final questions
for this round thank you
senator
one of the ways in which the court
receives information other than directly
from the parties in a case
is through a practice an established
practice of receiving
uh amicus briefs
amicus is a a term for friend friend of
the court briefs these are people who
are not
um parties to the case who don't have
that kind of interest in the case but
may have expertise or information or
arguments
that
they wish the court to hear
and
i think that that would be the primary
mechanism
by which if the court were to
decide to hear a case concerning
a matter that involved some technical
expertise
i would think that there might be amicus
briefs
related to the technology for example
um i have not looked at the court's
rules i would certainly want to discuss
with with um the courts
other justices
the
ways in which determinations are made
about which amicus briefs
are received and what disclosures are
related to them but the court does
receive amicus briefs uh in cases in
order to inform itself uh so that um it
can make a a decision related to the
issues in a case thank you judge jackson
thank you for your courage and your
grace your forthrightness and answering
my questions i look forward to the
opportunity to ask a few more later and
i yield mr chairman thanks senator assaf
senator tillis thank you mr chairman
judge jackson thank you for being here i
hope you got some rest last night and
congratulations very little senator but
that's all right me too
but uh but thank you for being here and
congratulations to your family and your
husband who has an impressive medical uh
uh list of accomplishments that he
should be proud of i'm sure that you are
too and thank you to your family the
public servants serving in the military
serving in law enforcement educating our
children
um
you're a role model family
i do want to go back this morning i
ended up turning to a channel that i
never watch
just to see
what
what was being said about the
proceedings
i thought it was interesting that they
were ridiculing some of my colleagues on
this side of the aisle for bringing up
the behavior of past
supreme court hearings this is really
the appropriate venue to do it i guess
we could talk about it when we're
reviewing intellectual property or
something else but contextually
this is the time to do that and i think
we all have to agree that the behavior
uh in the kavanaugh hearing was
inappropriate i hope we never get back
to it and i hope we can all agree that
many of the behavior or the positions
that some of my colleagues took on the
other side of the aisle with justice
barrett was abhorrent and we should
never do it again that's why i'm so glad
that for the most part
we behaved in an appropriate manner here
i'm going to get to some questions if
tom allows that that relates to some
other questions that my colleagues have
asked but
um
judge barrett uh did i understand
correctly that uh at a young age you won
a debate competition or was it oratory
competition
we were i was in speech and debate it
was one team and i did original oratory
as my
primary event and uh did you continue
your debate competition
did you continue to do that
first question
did you continue to do debate
competition
continue yes i mean were you doing that
in school and college i did not do it in
college no i did it i did it from middle
school through high school
um and stopped when i graduated high
school i did too and and i recall with
that that we would get assigned a topic
that wouldn't necessarily be one that we
agreed with but we had to argue it were
you ever in a situation or did you get
to pick a topic and only argue the side
that
so i did i didn't do what it sounds like
you're referencing is um extemporaneous
speaking
um i think i did that once in one
competition i did original oratory which
is where i wrote my own speech okay you
you've had an opportunity to debate a
lot as a defense uh counsel i would
assume
in in the court of law when you're
debating a position
and
the reason i ask that question
is that yesterday
senator kennedy was asking you about
the
expanding the court or what we call
court packing
you said
i haven't really thought about it
through the arguments on both sides
and i unders and
hear the argument on both sides so could
you briefly describe to me your
perception of the arguments on both
sides
my understanding
um of the argument is about whether or
not to expand
uh the court beyond the nine
uh justices that are on the court right
now the the nine seats that are there
um and
if you if you were to view i mean right
now it's
nine is fine
four or more
i mean that's really the two arguments
so do you understand or have you heard
any of the arguments for against either
side
i was i'm not even sure about the four
i've just heard people talking about
putting more justices on the court
um
expressing concerns that the court has
become politicized that uh the court has
become unbalanced in terms of uh what
people perceive to be views
of the majority of the justices and so
i've heard arguments about rebalancing
uh the court on that side and then
there's the argument that many uh on on
the diocese have
stated about
the inappropriateness of doing so the
concern that it might uh lead to
um
some kind of a war of
every time
there's a new president adding justices
to the court
the um
actually yesterday when uh senator
whitehouse i think it was senator booker
who
observed senator whitehouse's
presentation made a comment about how
rhode island
new jersey being a bit bigger
would have a bigger
graphic
to display i went back i think that
new jersey is
six times the size of rhode island
by square miles north carolina is 3 6
times the size of rhode island
and before my friends from texas
chime in i would i would let them know
that if
alaska were two states they'd be the
third largest state so
i
decided to use
the white house format
for
dark money so that we have a balanced
understanding of the fact that our
proceedings here
uh the aspirations for the court
there is an ecosystem out there on both
sides as a matter of fact we had a
judicial nominee who actually
participated in this ecosystem i think
you could reasonably assume
if they participated in that ecosystem
that they probably would have been an
activist judge
uh the the point that i make here
is that
we've seen this ecosystem mobilized to
support you and and i think uh judge
jackson you said you haven't had any
um
encounter with demand justice i don't
know if you've had any encounter with
some of these they're abbreviated or i'm
sorry uh yeah either acronyms are
abbreviated so i wouldn't expect you to
it would be interesting if we could for
the record
determine if you have had any
interactions but
with risk i have not senator i've never
seen
most of those that's good enough for me
i wouldn't expect you to be honest uh
sitting on the bench but
um but they are out there and they have
a specific plan
and their specific plan
as a matter of fact i was inspired by
uh senator whitehouse's seat so i went
out to demand justice
they have a specific plan
step one
four seats on the supreme court we must
add four seats on the supreme court to
restore balance which by their opinion
is a majority with their view
and their judicial philosophy
they're thrilled that president biden
has promised to a point of commission in
fact they're so thrilled that they want
to make sure that they can influence the
outside of the
the commission
uh
by uh endorsing their four-seat strategy
they want to recruit 25 000 volunteers
this is on their website their strategy
um to influence the commission's
recommendation
and then they want to nuke the
filibuster
51 votes
to make a decision that could ultimately
be to pack the courts
this is their stated goal they're proud
of it
senator whitehouse was talking about how
the prior president was influenced by an
organization i would i would say that
senator jackson
and almost everybody that the president
vetted before i'm sorry
judge jackson are on this list
so i think it's intellectually dishonest
to say that the administration that my
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle are not influenced by this
organization we've tracked some of the
fundraising and support and re-elections
they're engaged
and they're influenced by it but let me
tell you what i'm
really worried about with the court
packing
um
risk that we have today
we're talking about the ultimate
destruction of two institutions
back in january
senator schumer laid a vote down on the
floor
that ultimately would have reduced the
majority of 60 the filibuster limit of
60 to 51.
he was doing it
as a
as a way to pass a single bill but we
all know what happened
when
senator reid knew the executive calendar
for circuit court judges it led to
you only being subject to 51 votes to be
confirmed
that nuked the executive calendar
in january
senator schumer was laying the
groundwork for the same thing
now
i worry that that's the destruction of
the senate institution as far as i'm
concerned i think we have to be a
consensus-based organization we don't
need to be a hundred member house of
representatives and that vote happened
what disappointed me
most about that vote
is back when president trump
was calling on us and pressuring us to
nuke the filibuster
when we had control
of
congress
i signed on to a letter with more than
60 members to say that i would never do
that in the face of our pres in the face
of a republican president whose policies
are supported
i did that to send a very clear message
i respect this institution and i respect
the court which almost
certainly would have been
we would have had pressure
from our side of the aisle to pack the
court a little bit more
now every member who was here back when
we signed that letter who's on this
committee
changed their position
and voted
to potentially nuke the filibuster just
two months ago so i hope you can
understand my concern about the
political winds and the potential damage
that it could do to the senate
and
due
to
the supreme court i think it was
federalist paper 78
where hamilton talked about the
vulnerability or i think
the feebleness now he was arguing
i think the case for lifetime
appointments but i do think
that the supreme court is a fragile
institution
and i do believe
that if we think it's politicized now
think about how it would be
if we destroy the institution of the
senate so that a a strict party-line
partisan vote we expand the court
that's why court packing is important
and that's why we ask a question that i
know you're not going to answer
but i know that justice breyer
and justice ginsburg did
and if there's any supreme court justice
listening right now i wish that they
would speak up because i think your
institution is in peril and accelerating
it to a truly political body
is only one successful nuking of the
filibuster vote away in the u.s senate
this is serious stuff
i was at pricewaterhouse i was a partner
of pricewaterhouseback during the author
anderson enron scandal
i saw about a 100 year old top tier
big five consulting firm
ceased to exist
because their reputation suffered
if we pack the court
the only thing that you all have that
that the supreme court has is its
integrity and the esteem that the
american people and the trust they put
into it
packing the court
could cause the supreme court to lose
the trust of the american people
and i think if we want to expand the
court let's do it for the only valid
reasons maybe the justices come to us
and the chief justice come to us and say
the workload is too great the times have
changed and then convince 60 members of
this body to consider it
but when you've got a partisan
organization here that's putting a
pipeline of people in there that they
think think like them and have a
judicial philosophy like them how can
any reasonable person
think that this is just kind of fixing
the mechanics
it's a partisan decision that even some
of my colleagues on the other side of
the aisle have taken the bait
so much so
that they would reverse a commitment
that they made with me when they signed
that letter
to say they would never nuke the
filibuster and then nuke it
president biden's on that list too
back in 1983 he gave a rousing speech in
a judiciary committee hearing
saying don't pack the court
he gave a rousing speech on the senate
floor saying don't nuke the filibuster
but now we're in this posture to where
we could destroy two institutions
if we're not careful so i actually hope
that you can at some point study the
issue
thoroughly and understand the risk to
this
institution that you're likely to be
confirmed to
it's serious
and you could end up being there you'll
have a lifetime appointment you could
actually be there and witness its devise
real time
if we're allowing if we allow the court
to be packed
now
i want to talk uh
a little bit about
um
the
you i think you were you were part of a
of a case
in massachusetts
that some people are casting as a
pro-life versus pro-choice
issue now to be clear i am catholic and
i am pro-life and i'm proud to have
signed and ratified pro-life bills in
north carolina when i was speaker of the
house
that have withstood
judicial scrutiny
but i don't really think that case was
about pro-life i think it was about free
speech so i want to ask you a few
questions about it
um and maybe you could describe it to me
if your memory serves you but
it it seems to me
that the argument
that you you were a part of i think that
you uh
you joined uh with a couple of others um
it seemed as if the argument was because
the pro-life protesters were
threatening to danger threatening and
dangerous to women attempting to enter
the clinic i'm not necessarily saying
you put those words in the brief but
uh they were in there and they were
hostile noisy crowd in the face of
protesters now
it am i correct that
a part of the argument was because they
were noisy in your face protesters they
needed to be a little bit further away
than people who were pro-choice
advocates
because as i understand it i think the
underlying law in massachusetts was
ultimately struck down unanimously by
the supreme court is that correct
thank you senator
the brief that you oh by the way i
didn't i didn't expect you to respond to
my riff on packing the course yes just
to net it out it's a bad bad bad idea
but back on this i understand um
the brief that you are referencing was a
brief that i worked on
um right after finishing my supreme
court clerkship when i joined a big law
firm in massachusetts this is
19
maybe 2000
at the end of my clerkship
and
it is a first amendment free speech set
of arguments that the lawyers at my firm
i was a part of a team
representing clients who wanted to make
an argument about
buffer zones which at that time had not
yet been litigated all all the way up to
the supreme court was it was it a buffer
zone that put
pro-life and pro-choice people in the
same buffer
or one that argued that pro-life people
were in your face and perhaps needed a
bit better bigger buffer
than the pro-choice i was just trying
yes no i exited the case i
i'm
i believe that it was viewpoint neutral
meaning it wasn't about what the people
were saying it was about clearing a path
to allow people to enter the clinic
the laws at the time were
about how far
did people have to be kept back whether
they were pro-life or pro-choice because
if they were blocking the entrance do
you understand why the uh
the underlying
law was ultimately deemed
unconstitutional by the supreme court i
didn't follow the jurisprudence at that
time it had not been
and the first circuit i this was a first
circuit brief
um i don't remember what happened in the
district court but my clients wanted to
argue in the first circuit
that
the laws that allowed for
the clearing of the path so that people
could enter the clinic and have people
stand back
were constitutional and important and
the first circuit agreed i think
ultimately
um
i'm
i don't know exactly but i think
ultimately as you say there was some
litigation that went all the way to the
supreme court and
um the court
had other
jurisprudence about the extent to which
buffer zones are constitutional yeah
well it it it looked at i'm not an
attorney i watch law and order from time
to time and i'm uh
uh i'm not going to get into a debate
but but on its
face it almost looked as if
there was this notion that there was
uh
bad speech and good speech that that
somehow um
look i'm somebody who's had uh
protesters come to my house
get in my face and and be very nasty
four times by land and two times by sea
i live on a lake um
okay with them doing as long as they
stay off my line and the last case they
didn't
but um
it almost felt like to me that those
protesters who didn't like me
needed to be a little bit further away
than the protesters that maybe i would
allow to be a little bit closer it may
not be right but i'll make sure that i
get my facts right before this afternoon
in the second round i want to go to
sentencing
i'm not going to cover any of the ground
that my
colleagues have i'm sympathetic to some
of it not necessarily all of it because
i think the details
are something that we don't have
possession of i'm sure we're going to
talk a little bit more about that but
um i want to talk more about a a pattern
i know
uh and i was really um
impacted by your description of family
dinners and your your uncles uh
coming in in uniforms and putting their
gums up on the cupboard and having a
sense of pride that
that you uh you had family that served
in law enforcement um
there are a couple of cases uh i'm very
focused on law enforcement and backing
the blue i think that police law
enforcement i talk with a lot of them
their morale is low they feel like
defund the police and
some of these other efforts
are already making a very difficult and
dangerous job more difficult more
dangerous
there have been a few cases
where you have
recommended
lower
sentences that even i think the defense
attorneys have
but i'm sure that
if i were you and observing you
yesterday you would probably point to
some
mitigating circumstances or factors that
are not necessarily available to the
committee as a basis for doing that i
think in one case
uh the government recommended a 30-month
sentence and
the defense recommended 21 months and
you gave them 18 months and this was a
third conviction for assaulting an
officer there was another one
um that it was a lower
sentence for uh
there were officer assaults and it just
seemed like it went lower but i don't
want to get into those because you may
have
factors that uh
that you would point to that would
justify the decision
i i've got a question about now see
that's at an atomic level i mean you're
looking at the facts of the case you're
looking at the defendant and as you've
described in some of the other cases
here you made a judgment that you
thought was fair and that was in bounds
with
your peer group
but
back
at the beginning of the covet pandemic
i believe you made this statement and
i'll give you time to provide context if
it's out of context but in the interest
of time i'm only going to read the most
striking
you said the obvious increased risk of
harm that the covet 19 pandemic poses to
individuals who have been detained in
the districts that's the district of
columbia's correctional facilities
reasonably suggests that each and every
and i think that means everyone
every defendant who is currently in the
d.c
department of corrections custody and
who thus cannot take independent
measures to control their own hygiene
and distance themselves from others
should be released
i checked in april of 2020 i think
that's when you made the statement that
there were 12 or 1600 let's call 1200
i'll be conservative people in the
department of corrections
do i read that statement to say that you
felt given the circumstances of the time
they should all be released because
that's broad that's not looking at their
individual cases no senator you don't
read it correctly okay um it was not a
statement it was a line
in an opinion
and
the beginning of the covid19 pandemic
um was a really obviously horrible and
difficult time for all of us
um and
what was happening at the beginning in
the prisons which was part of the
criminal justice system that as judges
we
uh were involved i tracked it quick let
me i want you because i i do not want to
go over i don't go and i just but let me
let me just give you a little bit more
context
i've actually written letters to uh
to the department of justice
encouraging the release of non-violent
offenders
in north carolina at a federal
correctional facility i've also
supported
early release programs i voted and
supported the first step act
i as speaker of the house was the first
speaker in probably
two decades that actually did the
justice reinvestment act early release
of non-violent
prisoners but how can i not read this to
say that
perhaps they should be released
irrespective of the
the crime for which they've been charged
senator if you read two more sentences
down that is precisely what i focus on
this is a case united states versus
wiggins
where i was uh setting up my analysis as
to why i would not be releasing mr
wiggins in this case
he was arguing
uh essentially what i said in that
statement he was arguing
that the circumstances of covid19 which
at that point was rampant
in
the prisons we had not had a vaccine
there were
very difficult circumstances for
prisoners who could not be separated
from each other in the context of our
jails and as i say at the beginning of
that opinion
at that point kovid was ravaging the
jail
and the question for courts under the
statute that congress has enacted for
compassionate release was whether coven
19 a pandemic in the jail was an
extraordinary and exceptional
circumstance or extraordinary and
compelling circumstance that should
warrant release
what i said in that statement that you
read was it would seem as though
something like a deadly pandemic rampant
in the jails would justify
releasing everyone but i go on to say in
that very opinion
congress has indicated that we have to
take each case individually we have to
look at the harm to the community that
might be caused by the release of
individual people we can't just release
everybody i said in that opinion and so
i wanted to give you i'm sorry to
interrupt you but i'm on it's all right
on four minutes but
um
i i feel like
uh i also got i had my staff provided me
this morning in very very small type
recidivism and federal uh sentencing
outcomes
you know i i've said i'm on record as
saying that i want people out i want
them to have them an opportunity to
re-enter society become productive
members and i've got a track record for
ratifying bills to that effect and
supporting similar measures since i've
been here in the senate i'm going to
continue to work on it
but
tell me why
the the numbers that i'm looking here
we have
recidivism rate the most recent one that
i have before me and i'd be happy to
share what shared i'll ask with uh
uh to have this submitted to the record
but i think an eight-year look back says
that 49 of the people incarcerated are
rearrested within eight years
if you take a look at the types that are
are most likely to be reoffending it's
firearms offenders
robbery offenders
violent offenders reoffend it at a
higher rate than non-violent offenders
and so
if i look at this
and i i look at
your philosophy with respect and it's
admirable i said that the content of
your character would be demonstrated
this week my opening statement and it
has been and and one of the things that
are first among them are your compassion
and your belief that people can redeem
themselves
but if you look at some of the cases
that our
my colleagues have brought up
um
and if you
look at even even with the context that
you provided on the last statement about
the the department of corrections
statement and wiggins
um
can you understand how some of us may
think that your
your compassion could lead to bad
results based on the numbers that we
have here with recidivism that congress
may need to work more on that to make
sure
that we get it right um
can you understand how somebody
who
from our side of the aisle could see
that maybe
um there is some pattern to give the
benefit of the doubt to someone who has
been incarcerated in some cases with
very serious crimes
thank you senator um i don't
recall
saying anything about compassion in the
way that you're
describing it no no no no no i'm not
saying that if i take a look at uh your
your responses to
uh
some of my colleagues questions um and
your statements to some of the um
to some of the defendants it seems as
though you're a very kind person and
that there's at least a level of empathy
that enters into your treatment of a
defendant
that some could view
as a
uh
maybe
beyond what some of us would be
comfortable with with respect to
administering justice thank you for
letting me clarify um
the statements that i
made about my practices as a trial judge
which i'm no longer a trial judge but um
were
intended to explain how trial judges
operate and how they
impose sentences within the framework
that congress has provided
the statute that applies to us
tells us to look
at all of the various factors that
congress has set forward including the
nature and circumstances of the offense
the history of the character and
characteristics of the defendant and it
tells us
that we should be imposing a sentence
sufficient but not greater than
necessary to promote the purposes of
punishment congress also tells us that
one of the purposes of punishment is
rehabilitation
my
attempts
to communicate directly with defendants
is about public safety because most of
the people who
are incarcerated
via the federal system and even via the
state system will come out
will be a part of our communities again
and so it is to our entire benefit as
congress has recognized to ensure that
people who come out stop committing
crimes
and so
what i convey
or did when i was a trial judge
as i sentenced people to very lengthy
periods of incarceration
was
you are getting your day in court
you are able to say what you want to say
but you have to sit here and listen to
my reading into the record the victim
statements
in this case you have to go away
understanding
that
i am imposing consequences for your
decision
your decision to engage in criminal
behavior
and the reason why i did that i've said
is because i recognized as a defender
that there were lots of people in our
system who instead of taking
responsibility for what they had done
and then ultimately understanding the
harm and potentially not doing it again
instead of that those people were bitter
they were angry they were feeling
victimized because they didn't get a
chance to say what they wanted to say
because nobody explained to them that
drug crimes are really serious crimes
nobody said to them
do you understand that there are
children who will never have normal
lives because you sold crack to their
parents and now they're in a vortex of
addiction do you understand that mr
defendant i was the one in my sentencing
practices who explained to those things
in
an interest of furthering congress's
direction that we're supposed to be
sentencing people so that they can
ultimately be rehabilitated to the
benefit of society as a whole
i i appreciate that judge jackson i i
just still note that
virtually half of those people
statistically speaking that you gave
that speech to within eight years were
back in prison and and some in some
cases for more serious offenses than the
first incarceration thank you mr chair
thanks senator for that line of
questioning and i've noted that you
joined a letter with senator grassley
and myself in march of
uh
2020 at the earliest stages of this uh
talking about release under these
similar circumstances and of course we
all said at the same time low-risk
inmates would be considered but only
low-risk inmates yes and uh i wanted to
make that note for the record
we're going to start the second round of
questions 20 minutes each and i'll i'll
kick it off
this is an unusual document
this constitution of ours
which has taken up so much time in the
hearing a conversation about it
and
it is really at the core of public
service i don't know that there's a
place that you can take a job
at the federal level
in any branch of government without
taking an oath to defend this document
i don't know about other countries and
the oaths that might be required but we
even within the constitution spell out
the oath to be taken by the president of
the united states and it's to uphold and
defend this document
and there's great debate about
just
what this document means in today's
context
we understand the wisdom the inherent
wisdom of the document the fact that
we're still here some 230 years later
with the design
of a government
that has endured longer than virtually
any other democracy
which of course speaks to the wisdom of
the founding fathers and their plan for
this nation
but we also understand taking an honest
honest look at it
that you barely get into this document
article 1 section 2 then you run into a
problem
because in article 1 section 2 the
article that relates to congress
they talk about who will be counted for
apportionment among the states
and there is that awful reference to
three-fifths of all other persons
which though the document never mentions
the word slavery
are slaves
what was being spelled out here by the
founding fathers was how are we going to
count these slaves
and for apportionment purposes they
would be counted as three-fifths of a
person
which is a horrible notion by any
standard but the wise founding fathers
included it trying to deal with the
reality of their day
i hear debates back and forth of
originalists textualists and others and
you've been asked as often as
any nominee what your thought is you've
talked about stay in your own lane
judiciary and methodology and like but
i'd like to explore for just a moment
without asking you to get in any
particular fact pattern
the reality of a couple things
first
when the bill of rights was written the
first amendment to it made certain to
guarantee freedom of press
freedom of the press in 1790
was
of course referring to
a piece of paper
a newspaper uh and saying that there
would be freedom to engage in that
process in this democracy of america
now that freedom of press is referring
to this
and things have changed an awful lot
we have a circumstance now where
people no longer have just a handful of
television networks or
known publications washington post new
york times and such
but turn further sources of information
to places like facebook
and twitter and beyond
and we have
a real serious question about
what is a publication in america what
does it take to be a publication and be
press
is my blog that i publish tomorrow the
press guaranteed it with a
constitutional right that i have a right
to publish it as i wish say what i want
to say with certain boundaries
and i guess my question to you as we
look at this
is
how do you move from the language of
1789-1790
to the reality of 20 century
and make sure it's relevant
if more people are relying on facebook
and twitter for example for information
then they are
common sources of television and
newspapers
how do we rationalize that
they can say facebook and twitter
to a former president of the united
states you can't publish here
you're not going to be allowed to do it
and they've done that
so how do you reconcile that conflict of
the changing times the dramatic changes
in technology
what the founding fathers envisioned and
what we face today
thank you
senator
the challenges that you identify are the
types of things that the supreme court
is now
dealing with
we have
a
foundational document
that has text
and it has principles
it establishes freedoms and
foundational important
concepts that are intended to govern us
and that we are bound by
as
uh
as a society
there's modern technologies as you say
that have not um
that that
the framers the founders could not have
imagined the cell phone um and all the
other things that we
uh now
um rely upon
and
as i mentioned earlier the supreme court
in every court deals with individual
cases
disputes about issues
and
when the court gets an issue
that requires constitutional
interpretation
it
looks at the facts and circumstances of
the particular
case
and
the text
and principles of the constitution
in light of the times in which they were
written
and analogizes
to present day
so the supreme court for example has
considered the cell phone issue with
respect to
uh the
constitutional principle of unreasonable
searches and seizures which is a
protection from
a government intrusion
that the framers called an unreasonable
search
the text unreasonable search
is not does not have an inherent
definition what the supreme court has
done is looked back
at the time of the founding to determine
what
kinds of intrusion
would have been covered when those words
were written into the constitution
and to the extent that the
at the time of the founding those words
covered things like police officer
intruding into your home and looking
into your papers and affairs
then
the supreme court analogizes
that circumstance
to the modern day circumstance of a cell
phone which now is in all
respects says the court like rifling
through your purple papers and affairs
so it's a process of
uh understanding what the core
foundational principles are in the
constitution as captured by the text
as originally intended and then applying
those principles to modern day
i'll just give you two
illustrations of
my thinking on this and my
frustration or at least
understanding of the challenge let's say
let's put it that way senator feinstein
and i joined in legislation
uh several years ago to talk about
confidential confidentiality of sources
for news entities
and whether or not a person could a
reporter could be compelled to disclose
those sources
the effort really drew some of the
best and brightest in the news business
to come testify for the committee
the effort failed and faltered over what
is a publication
who is a publisher
who is
in the business of dispensing news does
it involve
money has to
pass between them for this to be
official publication or can i just put
up on my blog what i wish and
and resist any efforts
to discover my sources
that was one of the serious issues that
we faced we also took a look i take a
look at
where this is going in in terms of
the future
and our entities that we rely on for
news so often
and
i'm going to leave it at that because i
think you've addressed the general and
don't want to get into more specifics uh
nor should you but um when people pledge
that
you know they are originalists we're
sticking with the original words
you better have your mind open to the
reality that this world is changing and
changed and many of those principles are
sound today
but the challenges of interpreting them
with the reality of today's technology
uh is is a challenge very difficult one
which you will face in the court i'm
going to try to set an example here we
have 20 minutes and i'm going to try to
yield back some part of it i see that
senator cornyn is here and i'm glad he
is because i'm going to address an issue
which he raised yesterday and again this
morning
and i wanted to do it while he was
physically present so that when he gets
his turn he can address it i'm sure he
will
yesterday senator graham said that you
had gone too far in calling the
government quote a war criminal and
pursuing charges against a terrorist
later senator cornyn asked judge jackson
i quote you referred to the secretary of
defense and president united states as
war criminals why would you do something
like that
as i noted yesterday and repeat this
morning these charges don't hold up
cnn fact check said quote both graham
and cornyn left out important context
specifically neither mentioned that
jackson's allegation of war crimes was
about torture
also jackson didn't explicitly use the
phrase war criminal the new york times
noted that the allegation quote is a
distortion and lacks context the new
york times went on to say
jack did not specifically call the
former president defense secretary war
criminals she was one of several lawyers
in 2005
signing four essentially boilerplate
habeas corpus petitions on behalf of
detainees at guantanamo that claimed the
us government had tortured the men that
such acts constitute war crimes that's
in quotes the petitions each named mr
bush and mr rumsfeld along with two
senior military officers who oversaw the
guantanamo detention operation in their
official capacities as respondents
washington post noted and i quote
one key thing to note as law professor
stephen vellanic does is that bush and
ron prunsville are named in petitions
because they have to be to clear
procedural hurdles indeed those
petitions later named barack obama after
the administration changed another is
that they are named in their official
capacities not because of actions they
personally took as individuals
they continued but the larger point is
that jack jackson was acting as a
detainee's lawyer in her role as public
defender and one of the underpinnings of
the american justice system that is even
the most reviled alleged criminals have
the right to a vigorous defense would
you like to comment on that
statement that i just made
well senator um
i would just say
that
[Music]
public defenders
don't choose their clients
and yet they have to
provide
vigorous advocacy that's the duty of a
lawyer
and as a judge now
i see the importance
of having lawyers
who
make arguments
who
make allegations
in the context of a habeas petition
especially early
in
the process
of the
response to the horrible attacks of 9 11
lawyers were helping the courts
to assess
the
permissible extent of executive
authority
um by
making arguments and
we were assigned as public defenders
we had very little information
because of the
confidentiality or classified nature of
a lot of the
record
and as
an appellate lawyer
it was my obligation
to
file habeas petitions on behalf of my
clients
thank you judge i'm going to try to set
an example by yielding back about seven
minutes my time i invite my colleagues
to follow that example if they wish
senator grassley you're next yeah
uh
before i start i like to make a brief
point
yesterday senator durbin referenced
congress's effort to stop child
pornography
and the exploitation of minors
i've worked on this issue for decades in
1983.
i supported the protection of
children against sexual exploitation act
in 2012 i sent a letter to the
sentencing commission well
judge jackson was vice chair in the
letter i encouraged the sentencing
commission not to lower sentences for
child pornography
i said that quote
it would be a disservice to the american
people to have the commission issue a
report that advocates for the reduction
in sentencing for a class of criminals
who cause profound and lasting damage
to their victims and of cold
i'd like to have that
put in the record
yesterday you referred to your record of
decisions as the best thing to look at
when explaining and evaluating your
nomination
but you also said that you haven't had
enough cases involving constitutional
law to develop a judicial philosophy
if you haven't had
to develop a philosophy
for deciding cases yet what else do you
think would be helpful for us to look at
so respectfully senator i do have a
philosophy the philosophy
is my methodology it is a philosophy
that
um
i have developed from practice
um unlike some judges who come to
appellate work from academia
and who have
some overarching theory of the law
i approach cases
from
experience from practice
and
consistent with my constitutional
obligations so my philosophy is one in
which i
look at cases impartially consistent
with my independence as a judicial
officer
i
understand
my limited role in the constitutional
scheme and therefore take very seriously
all of the constraints on the exercise
of my authority that exists
in our
system what that means is that at the
beginning of every case
i am setting aside my personal views i'm
the three steps you gave us yes sir
yes so you don't have to go into that
let me go on there
should the supreme court overrule a
precedent when it is clear to the
justices that the president
was wrongly decided
thank you senator starry decisis which
is the principle
that
the supreme court
uses
at the outset it's the sort of
background rule of
judicial
maintenance of
precedence
in order to have predictability
stability
uh in the law
is the kind of principle that the court
begins with when it
is asked to overrule or
uh revisit a precedent
and the court has developed certain
factors
that it looks at before it actually
undertakes to
reverse a precedent
one of those factors is
the view that the precedent it's
reconsidering is wrong
but that's not the only factor
the court also uh determines
in addition to whether or not the pr the
prior precedent was egregiously wrong
the court has said
um the court looks at whether there's
been reliance
on that prior precedent whether the
precedent is workable or has proven
workable over time
whether
the cases in the area
of the precedent have shifted such that
the precedent itself is no longer on
firm foundation
and whether there have been either new
facts or a new understanding of the
facts
that
give rise to a need to revisit the
precedent so it's not just
um
a look at whether or not it's wrong and
it's important that the court take into
account all of those factors because
starry decisis meaning letting the
president stand
is a very important
pillar of the rule of law
when is it appropriate for a judge to
impose a sentence enhancement under the
guidelines
thank you senator
the federal sentencing guidelines
are crafted
to assist courts in
making sentencing determinations within
the broad range
that congress prescribes for cases
for for crimes
so in the typical case
a defendant is convicted of some crime
in the federal system they're usually
very serious crimes
and
congress will say judge you can give
that person a sentence anywhere between
0 and 20 years for example
the sentencing guidelines
are designed to set out
a series of factors
that judges
should be looking at when they decide
what they're going to sentence that
particular person to
and those factors will be things like
if this is a violent crime does the
person have a weapon if this is a
violent crime was there any injury
and so the judge is looking at these
facts in many cases horrible facts and
calculating the guidelines based on what
we call enhancements each one of those
different characteristics or conditions
is an enhancement
so you ask when is it important to
um
when it's appropriate well the judge has
to calculate the guidelines
in every case that's how we start the
process
but under the statutes in addition to
calculating the guidelines with all of
those enhancements
the way our system now works is you
determine what the guideline range of
punishment is going to be
and then congress says you look at a
series of other factors in addition to
the guideline range
and at the end of the day the judges in
the system now
are choosing
sentences based on both the
consideration of the guidelines and also
the consideration of the statutory
factors that congress has put forward
have you ever declined to impose an
enhanced sentence on a defendant because
you disagreed with the enhancement as a
policy matter
thank you senator
yes and the reason
is because of supreme court case law
concerning
the way in which the guideline system
operates
the supreme court
has
determined
in a case we discussed yesterday
that the guidelines are no longer
binding on judges meaning
the guidelines you calculate but you
don't have to stay
in the guideline range anymore that was
the supreme court's booker case
in and i can't remember if it's in that
case or in subsequent case law but the
supreme court has also made clear that
when you are
calculating the guideline range in the
new system that we're in right now
judges are free they the supreme court
has said
to
decide in particular cases
whether as a quote-unquote policy matter
they disagree with a particular
enhancement that is the state of the law
that is what the supreme court has said
judges are permitted to do
in cases
and so i have in certain cases
given
the way in which the guidelines are
operating
the disparities that are created in
cases
i have at times identified various
enhancements that i have disagreed with
as a policy matter because the supreme
court has said
that that's the authority of a
sentencing judge in our system
are nationwide injunctions
constitutional
well
senator um you you should do
thank you for letting me address
that
circumstance
the reason why i paused is because um
that what what i have issued is not
technically a nationwide injunction
people call
um
call it that but in a particular set of
cases
administrative agency cases that are
brought under the administrative
procedure act
these are challenges to
agency actions
like agency rules that they have
promulgated
and if the challenge is to the
procedures that the agency undertook
to create the rule
the statute that applies the
administrative procedure act tells the
court
that if you agree with the plaintiff
that the agency rule is faulty
procedurally
the remedy in the statute is to
invalidate the rule
that's what congress tells judges to do
now technically that's not a nationwide
injunction that is
invalidating a rule
that the agency has enacted
it may have nationwide effects because
the agency may have
implemented its rule nationwide but what
the court is doing
is not reaching out and touching
everyone in the country the court is
directing the government that has
promulgated that rule
that the rule is invalid and that's what
the statute tells us we have to do in
those cases
that's different than a nationwide
injunction because a nationwide
injunction would be a situation
in which we're not dealing with the rule
we're not dealing with the
administrative procedure act
we're dealing with a particular case in
which something has happened between the
plaintiff and the defendant
and the court says based on what
happened in this case
i'm going to tell everybody in the
country that you can't
the defendant you can't operate in this
way anymore i'm going to find on the
basis of this particular case and i'm
going to join everyone in the country
not to do that anymore that's a
nationwide injunction which is not what
i've done
in i think the cases that you're talking
about
how can the judiciary address
concerns about foreign shop forum
shopping
given the rise of nationwide injunctions
well um
forum shopping
is
um
is a concern that arises
when
litigants
seek to
[Music]
go to different places in the country
where they think that they may get a
better result
and it's something that congress can
address because congress has the power
to
determine
various
aspects of judicial processes
explain the political question doctrine
and then what standards would you apply
to determine
whether a claim before you
implicates a political question
so the political question doctrine um is
a doctrine that relates to
uh the jurisdiction of the court
as i mentioned um
the courts are in
um
a particular branch of government the
judicial branch that is limited in its
power
the courts can't
make policy they can't reach out into
the world and decide that certain things
are good or bad and then address them
they have to wait for cases to come
and decide them
and when a case comes
has to be presenting a question of law
for the court to answer it if a person
comes to the court
and they ask the court to answer
something that is properly in the
province of congress if they ask a
political question
then the court has to say i'm sorry
that's not my role
so i had for example a case
that involved
um
uh yemeni
citizens
who
um
i'm trying to get the facts exactly
right but they
um had relatives they were i think they
were resident in the united states and
they had
relatives in yemen
a war-torn area this is um a few
few years ago
and
they came to the court
me
asking
if i could direct the administration
to extract
their
relatives from yemen
that they wanted me to order
the
executive branch to send in troops and
get their relatives out because it was
um
obviously dangerous for their relatives
to be
in that country
and what i said in that circumstance is
essentially i don't have jurisdiction to
do that because what you're asking me to
do
is
a political question that the question
of when and where troops can be sent and
who
um can be extracted from foreign
governments belongs with the executive
branch
and so you have to ask them
and so i said i have no jurisdiction
that's a political question doctrine
and it's well established in in our law
yesterday in response to a question from
senator durbin
you said that a judge
as a judge
you are quote
trying
in every case to stay in your lane and
end the vote that's the same time you
gave us the three steps you go through
as you work yourself through a case you
also described the text of law as a
constraint
on your authority
but in several cases uh i'll list make
the road new york
aflci
versus trump
watervale marine companies and others
the dc circuit reversed your decision or
criticized your reasoning for failing to
follow a clear and unambiguous text
why didn't the clear text of the laws
constrain your authority in these cases
um thank you senator
you mentioned three cases
um
certainly with respect to the second one
the dc circuit
didn't say that the text was clear and
in fact that's
what happens in cases that judges at the
trial level
do their best to make interpretations in
that case
it involved a channeling provision this
is um
afgh versus trump
it involved a
provision a statute that was designed to
channel
um
the
um
judicial authority
into an agency
and i interpreted the statute and i
thought that the arguments that were
being made
um the claims that were being made were
not ones that congress had intended to
channel and i went through the analysis
and i explained my reasoning i
still had jurisdiction i went on
to address
uh the merits which is the duty of the
judge if they determine they do have
jurisdiction
the
dc circuit disagreed they wrote an
opinion
that
interpreted the statute differently with
respect to those claims but it was a
case of first impression as to what
those claims meant and whether they were
supposed to be channeled or not and that
happens
district judges do their best and
sometimes the court of appeals in the
supreme court haven't spoken to the
issue and the parties disagree
in make the road um i explained
that
what i was attempting to do in light of
congress's enactments not only the
particular immigration
provision but also the
uh administrative procedure act was
reconcile
the statutes of congress which is
something that um the courts also are
supposed to do that there are statutory
interpretation cannons that make clear
that courts are supposed to
understand that congress intends for its
statutes to work together and to the
extent that you are interpreting and the
claim is made that allows you to do that
that's
the sort of way in which interpretation
is done i can go through my actual
analysis i did it yesterday as we talked
but
um there was a good faith disagreement
between me and the court of appeals
which gets to decide
as to what the language meant and
whether or not
congress actually intended to exclude
the apa
using that language under those
circumstances thank you very much
senator lee
thank you chair
and welcome back judge jackson i
uh i know yesterday was a grueling day
of questions i commend you for your
poise your endurance your thoughtful
answers
uh
i felt uh
privileged to be here for hours of that
and you had even more hours
but i want you to know the reaction in
my own state of vermont
i've gotten all kinds of emails and
calls and
from friends
uh
across the political spectrum they're
all been praising you
and they said
they realized that a lot of the
questions that were logged at you had
nothing at all to do with
your qualities as being
being on the supreme court but were
some members unfortunately aiming for
what
a sound bite that they might be able to
put on a political
uh
website where it now is
for example we heard some overheated
claims
yes it's your representation of
guantanamo detainees
somehow signaled your policy preference
with how the united states has
dealt with those detainees
and every single member
of this committee especially those of us
who
have been
assigned as counsel in cases
to know better than to complete a
nominee's past representation
or their policy positions
or to argue the nominee espoused their
clients viewpoint simply by choosing to
represent them
so your policy views aside
can you reiterate why it's so important
for our courts to have the benefit of
the best possible legal representation
on both sides of any case
and especially in cases where we are in
uncharted
legal and constitutional
waters
yes thank you senator
so
i've been a judge for uh
almost a decade and
what i've learned is that
as part of my duty
to render decisions
consistent with my judicial oath in
support of our constitution and the rule
of law
i need to consider
all of the arguments related to
the dispute
that is being
brought in my courtroom
i need to hear from
not only the parties who are prosecuting
a case for example a crime
but also from
the defense and some of these crimes
are terrible crimes
our constitution
is designed
to ensure that the government
affords due process to people who are
being accused of crimes
and
one might think even
it's it's even more important in in a
way
in a case in which someone is so reviled
it's kind of like the first amendment
it's a protection for
um for unpopular
views
um it's it's needed when there's a
chance that the government will
uh suppress or uh you know
uh do something
that's untoward
and so in the criminal justice system
we have many many amendments that are
designed to make sure
that unpopular people people who are
accused of doing terrible things
are still treated fairly by the
government
and that's a limitation on government
power which is the
um
which is the framework of our
constitution it is about limiting
um government overreach and so in the
criminal justice system you can imagine
and the framers imagined a world in
which the government would use its
authority
to deprive people of their liberty
to to throw people in jail to lock lock
them up and throw away the key
to not give people the opportunity to
make arguments
about their freedom
that would be
a real exercise of
government power government overreach
and so the framers said what we're going
to do
is we're going to put in our
foundational documents
a protection
for people
that the government is accusing of crime
and that's not to say that the people
are innocent that's not to say that they
haven't done terrible things what it's
about
is ensuring that the government
does what is required
in order to ensure all of our liberty it
protects all of us because there might
be someone who who is innocent
and the government if the government is
able to just do whatever it wants in
criminal process we are all at risk well
and i think we've all seen
cases where that happened i i mentioned
to you yesterday that i spent nearly a
decade as a prosecutor
especially when i had serious cases i
want the best defense attorney possible
on the other side
i want a case that
um
if if i want to usually win up on appeal
automatically if it carried a heavy
penalty
i wanted the court the appellate court
to look at and say
okay there were not errors
of counsel on either side
and but i also as a strong proponent of
our constitution
i think what you're saying is something
i totally agree with we have to have uh
we have to have
the individual's rights protected it
doesn't mean the defense counsel
is in favor of murder or rape or what uh
armed robbery but the rights have to be
protected
let me tell you about another area i've
authored and i've long championed the
bipartisan john lewis voting rights
advancement act
i think it would help
curtail the
growing wave of voter suppression
sleeping across our country
again something we don't have to worry
about in vermont unfortunately do in
other states
i'm passionate
about this legislation i've always
believed that our democracy is stronger
when we expand not
shrink the ranks of our citizens have
fully
participated
i believe our democracy goes stronger
with your historic nomination
and your presence before us today
and i've told you privately how my
family members feel about that
why is it important for our democracies
institutions
courts and all others
to reflect
the rich diversity of our nation's
citizenry
thank you senator um
one of the things we've been talking
about is the
difference between the judicial branch
and the other branches of government
we have three branches in our
federal system
and
the
legislative branch has certain powers
and it can do certain things
to ensure that its prerogatives are
achieved
and the executive branch has the power
of might they the the president controls
the military
the judicial branch its force in our
system
is the protection of the rule of law
which can only be done
by essentially the consent of the
governed
it can only be done if
people in our society believe
decide and agree that they're going to
follow
what it is that courts
decide
and so one of the reasons
why
having a diverse
judicial branch
is important
is because it lends
and bolsters public confidence in our
system
we have a diverse
society
in the united states there are people
from all over who
come to this great nation and make their
lives
um and
when people see that the judicial branch
is comprised of a variety of people who
are have taken the oath to protect the
constitution and who are doing their
best to
interpret the laws consistent with that
oath
it lends confidence
that the rulings that the judge that
that the court is
uh handing down are fair and just that
everything has been considered
that no one is being excluded because of
a characteristic like race or gender or
anything else and that's that's
important i would also say that um
that it's important from the standpoint
of role modeling
um
that i have
been so
touched by
the numbers of people who've reached out
to me
in this period of time
to say how much it is meant to their
daughters to their sons
to the next generation
that i've been appointed
um
to nominated and hopefully confirmed
well i agree with you guys
certainly seen that within my own family
you know we we do have areas where we
agree on things on this uh committee
uh judge uh senators grassley and
senator cornyn
myself and others i believe in uh
transparency
as part of our democracy we've done this
with the freedom of information act
we've updated a number of years senator
cornyn and i have been
the key sponsors of legislation joined
by senator grassley and senator durbin
and others
to
improve the freedom information act
you've talked about the detailed
opinions you've written to try to do the
same thing
uh
i think it's safe to say you believe
transparency is central to the duties of
a
judge do you intend to
carry that attitude when
and you will and you will
become a member of the u.s supreme court
thank you senator
the value of public confidence um which
i was just discussing
i think is enhanced
when the public understands
the reasons that a judge
renders his or her ruling
one of my
mentors used to say
people think the judicial branch is so
secretive but in fact the judicial
branch is the only branch that actually
has to
tell everyone
that actually has to
write their opinions and explain why it
is that they did what they did
and so
i tried um i've tried in the nearly 10
years that i've been on on the bench
to
make
my rulings
transparent to explain
all of the inputs that i have considered
with respect to
the case
to
lay out
the law as i see it in interpreting what
what
congress for example has done in in with
respect to a particular uh case and what
legal provisions that i think are
relevant to the dispute
and then to explain my analysis
why am i
granting
this motion or denying this claim
and my hope is that it will
help people to be confident in my
reasoning and even if they disagree with
it
they will understand
what it is that i think and i think
that's important for
uh public confidence
in promoting the rule of law well you
know you had talked about your
clerking for justice prior how to open
up doors of opportunity i remember
so well our conversation in my office in
the president protests office
uh talking before you
these heritage began
uh
you told
me what you thought i mean to your
parents and your family
uh
your husband your daughters
uh your parents who
have been here throughout this
and what it would have meant to your
grandparents
you said you were the lucky first
inheritor
of dr king's civil rights legacy
uh i keep a daily journal i wrote that
down
uh i just uh
it means a lot so let me
do this sort of a open-ended question
you patiently answered our questions
this week i told you the reaction in
vermont was
disappointment and some that were
obviously political
um i heard that from both republicans
and democrats
because their i think it should be your
legal
uh thoughts in supreme court
so
i'd like to give you an opportunity to
speak directly to the american people
including our little state of vermont
is there anything you want to convey to
them about what kind of supreme court
justice you would be
if and when you're confirmed that's all
it's all yours your honor
thank you senator um
well first let me just address
my comments to you
in your office
which is something that i've said
um in speeches because it
speaks to
who i am and what i value
um
my parents grew up in
florida
under lawful segregation and what that
means is that when they were coming
through
middle school in high school
they were not allowed to go to school
with white students this is um in the
era before
uh and right after the brown versus the
board decision there was lawful
segregation in places in this country
and it was after that time
that dr king
made his famous comments that people
uh mention
uh about having a dream uh where people
can be judged by the
not by the color of their skin but by
the content of their character
and
i then was born in 1970 and the contrast
between
my reality growing up in florida
and my parents reality growing up in
florida
like night and day
in terms of the
opportunities that were available to me
that weren't available to
um
judge motley who is one of my
role models in in the law
and so what my
being here i think is about
at some level
um is about the the progress that we've
made in this country in a very short
period of time i would say it seems like
a long time but one generation
we've gone
from from the reality of my parents
upbringing to the reality of mine
and i do consider myself having been
born in 1970 to be
the first generation to benefit
from the civil rights movement from the
legacy
of
all the work
of so many people
that went into
changing the laws in this country so
that people like me could have an
opportunity to be sitting here before
you today
what i would hope to bring
to the supreme court
is very similar
to what
uh 115
other
justices have brought which is their
life experiences
their perspectives
and mine include
being
a trial judge
being an appellate judge being a public
defender being
a member of the sentencing commission
in addition to my being a black woman uh
lucky inheritor of the civil rights
dream
and
in my capacity as a justice
i
would do
what i've done for the past decade
which is to rule
from a position of neutrality
to look
carefully at the facts and the
circumstances of every case without any
agendas without any uh
attempt to push the law in one direction
or the other to look only at the facts
and the circumstances interpreting the
law consistent with the constitution and
presence
and to render
rulings
that
i believe and that i hope that people
would have confidence
thank you and
chair durbin i've had the opportunity to
be here
the first
justice i got to uh
hold on was john paul stevens
nominated by
president gerald ford
proud to vote for him
and uh
it's a long arc
uh judge jackson but
i am so proud of your answers and i
appreciate yield back
thank you senator lee let's take a break
for about 15 minutes thank you thank you
very much judge
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
all right
thank you
[Music]
god
me
oh
[Music]
you
yes
[Music]
is
[Music]
yes
i think
okay
oh
is
yes
[Music]
good
yes
decisions
boys
thank you
uh
around
[Music]
[Music]
oh
i knew you were here
wow
um
i'm really bad about it
oh
have a great day
oh yeah
now
[Music]
oh
that was my dad
okay
questioning will resume
senator graham
thank you mr chairman uh good morning
judge
thank you sorry good morning senator
i want to comment on the the last
exchange
and judge that this is not of your
making so it's really not about
about you but representative greene
who's a
fine man came up and
said he thought the exchange between you
and senator leahy at the
end about the arc of time and how far
we've come as a nation was powerful i
agree
and i guess here's my point i'm trying
to make to the american people to my
democratic colleagues i wish you had
that same attitude when an
african-american conservative
is appointed to high office in the
judiciary
so what happened with janice rogers
brown
in 2003
she was an african-american nominee for
the d.c district court
54 years old a little bit older new but
pretty close
she was a daughter and granddaughter of
sharecroppers a childhood in alabama
under jim crow
she was a
single mother
a member of the
california supreme court
instead of celebrating
how far we've come
my democratic colleagues filibustered
her ascension to the d.c circuit court
because it's well known on our side
that we
were very much considering her
to be the first african-american woman
on the supreme court
so rather than this wonderful exchange
which was wonderful
representative greene
where were you and others
when there was a wholesale assault on
her nomination
nowhere to be found
the filibuster was used for two years
to stop her nomination
and we eventually did the gang of 14 of
which i was apart so that she could make
it through
after two years of wedding
this is what the current president said
when he was in the senate joe biden
asking about her janice rogers brown
being on the supreme court i can assure
you that would be a very very very
difficult fight and she probably would
be filibustered
that's what he said
about an african-american
conservative nominee by president bush
who had served five years on the
california supreme court
we're not going to live in america like
that any longer to my democratic
colleagues
if you're a person of color
a woman
supported by liberals is pretty easy
sailing but if you're miguel estrada
janice rogers brown
amy comey barrett
on and on and on
your life gets turned upside down
you had nothing to do with that
i just make this observation that when
you come up to me and talk about how
moving the exchange was i agree
and i just want to remind you there was
somebody else
of color a woman of color
that was picked for the
dc circuit one of the highest courts in
the land
that did not meet the same fate
and
those days should be over
uh do you believe illegal immigrants
should be allowed to vote judge jackson
thank you senator
under our laws you have to be a citizen
of the united states in order to vote
so the answer would be no
it's not consistent with our laws so the
answer is no okay why do they do that in
new york
senator i'm not aware of the
circumstances all right well that's a
good answer the answer is no
can an unborn child feel pain at 20
weeks in the birthing process
senator i don't know
are you aware of the fact that
anesthesia is provided to the unborn
child at that time period
if there's an operation to save the
baby's life because they can in fact
feel pain
or you wear that i am not aware of that
well that may come before you one day so
just keep an open mind that's the only
thing i
ask you to do
you said uh just a bit ago
and that you
apply the law
and the facts and call them as you see
them is that right that is correct son
okay and you look at the statute as the
way it's written
and you try to apply it in this plain
meaning is that correct that is correct
senator have you heard of a case called
uh
make the road versus mcmacklin
make the road new york yes yeah okay
make the road in new york who are they
um
make the road new york is a non-profit
that
represents
um
various individuals in this sort of
immigration law
world they're a non-profit advocacy
group for immigration issues
and did you know they received large
donations from the arabella network
and from george sources open society
foundation network
no okay well they did
now in that case
what was the issue
the issue in that case was a
challenge
to a change in administration policy
concerning
[Music]
expedited removal which is a
policy
that congress enacted
in order to
[Music]
expedite certain removals in the
immigration system ordinarily
um
before expedited removal asylum cases do
not fall in this category right
well trust me on that because the
statute says it doesn't
if a person who could otherwise be
subject to expedited removal
makes and has a credible fear of torture
in their country they can be can they
make that determined they can be
determined right uh to
qualify for regular removal rather than
right expedited removal so expedited
removal is a creature of congress folks
and if you've been here two years or
less the statute
the the statute i'm sorry the statute
the statute would allow the
administration in office
to have expedited removal avoiding a lot
of the
the hurdles that would exist otherwise
for people here two years or less
so in the obama of even bush years
they did not look at it in terms of
applying it to everybody
some people coming by air got
ex-expedited removal others didn't
the trump administration decided to use
the authority given to it by congress
to remove all eligible cases
two years or less
under the expedited removal statute is
that a fair summary
well senator i would um say
say it differently
we'll say it differently all right
the statute that you've put up
indicates that congress is giving
the
department it says the attorney general
but now it's the department
the ability
to determine
what category of aliens if you've two
years or less
yeah but but but importantly
um the authority
was
it was not congress saying two years or
less what congress said is
you
agency
have the authority to determine what
category of persons
between
who have been here between zero
and 24 months which is two years yeah no
but what
forgive me senator i'm just what i'm
trying to explain is that
the authority given to the agency was to
determine
what length of time expression to make
that what what length of time it was not
the authority to deport everyone
who's been here for 24 months it was the
authority to determine what length of
time a person has to be here in order to
be subjected to expedited removal here's
what the statute said
the attorney general which is actually
the
dhs secretary
may apply clauses one and two of the
sub-paragraph to any and all aliens
described in subclass 2
as designated by the attorney general
actually dhs
such designation shall be in the soul
and unreviewable discretion of the
attorney general and may be modified at
any time
now i've been in this business for quite
a while
what the trump administration did was to
use the discretion
given to it by statute
in a way different than prior
administrations
this advocacy group the arabella
supported advocacy group tried to strike
it down
you rule for them
here's what
the dc circuit court said about your
ruling
there could hardly be a more definitive
expression
of congressional intent to leave the
decision about the scope of expanded
removal
within statutory bounds to the
secretary's independent judge judgment
the forceful phrase sole and
unreviewable discretion
buys exceptional terms
such designation
shall be in the sole and unreviewable
discretion of attorney general and may
be modified at any time
to those of us in the law writing
business
i don't know how you could tell a judge
more clearly
that the administration the agency in
question
has discretion to do certain things
within the
statute so this is an example to me and
you may not agree where the plain
language of the statute was completely
wiped out by you
you reached a conclusion because you
disagreed with the trump administration
and the d.c circuit court of appeals
said
as i've quoted just a minute ago there
could hardly be a more definitive
expression of congressional intent to
lead the decision
about the scope of expedited removal
within the statutory bounds to the
secretary's independent judgment
that to me is exhibit a
of activism
let's go back to the child pornography
cases
senator would you allow me to yes please
thank you
the statute and the circumstances that
you reference are
accurate in so far as that is what the
statute says it's not all of it it
doesn't describe the designation process
that i was trying to articulate
and
uh it doesn't address the fact that
congress has another statute that is
presumptively applied in agency cases
to tell
agencies how to exercise discretion
there's also dc circuit case law
that says that in addition to having
that procedural statute be presumptive
even
very clear
uh designations of authority to an
agency
may still be subject to congress's other
directions regarding how to exercise the
discretion that argument fell on deaf
ears understood that that's our
appellate process i've got other things
i want to talk about you've given an
explanation but it didn't work the dc
circuit court said there could hardly be
a more definitive expression of
congressional intent this is good as it
gets
there's no way to write a statute saying
discretion lies in an agency it's soul
it's non-reviewable so you're not
convincing me
other than
activism and we can talk about it all
day long but i do i agree with the dc
court this to me is an example exhibit a
of a judge ignoring limitations placed
in the law by congress to get a result
they want it child pornography
i have no doubt that you find child
pornography disgusting as the rest of
america
you're a mother you seem to be a very
nice person
are you aware of how many images are out
there on the internet
involving children
and sexually compromising situations
senator i'm not aware of the numbers but
i've seen the images
in
2021
the national center for missing and
exploited children
cyber tipline received 29.3 million
reports of apparent child sexual
exploitation containing 85 million
images videos and other files
that's in 2021
it's up
in 2019
it was
less
so there's an epidemic of this on the
internet
that if you go out on the internet there
are millions of pictures of kids being
abused when it comes to sentencing child
pornography possession cases
do you retain routinely discount the
fact that a computer was used
thank you senator for allowing me to
address
this
concern
the guidelines related to child
pornography
were drafted
at a time in which a computer was not
used
for
the majority if not almost all of these
kinds of
horrible crimes
the guidelines
have enhancements in them in two areas
that you said you disagree what are
those two areas
at the time that the guidelines were
drafted it was a an aggravating factor a
substantial aggravating factor
to use a computer in order to distribute
and disseminate the images
because
the ordinary crime was not
committed by computer so the would you
agree with me that computers are sort of
the
venue of choice for child pornographer
people
yes okay so here's my point
if you believe as i do the computer has
created a bigger demand
there are more photos out there because
of the internet more websites
exposing this garbage
would you want to deter people from
going down that road
senator this crime is among the most
difficult no answer my question would
you want to deter people from going down
the road of using the computer that
allows these people to have access to
millions of photos because of the
technology
i want those people to turd so if you're
listening to my voice today and you're
on a computer looking at child
pornography and you get caught i hope
you're in your sentences enhanced
because the the computer in the internet
is feeding the beast here that all these
images out there
are going to be more over time because
people use computers
now didn't you also say
that the number of images should not be
considered as a sentence enhancement
senator with respect to the computer one
of the most effective deterrents
is one that i imposed in every case and
that
judges across the country impose in
every case which is substantial
substantial supervision
you think it is a bigger deterrent to
take somebody who's on a computer
looking at sexual images of children and
the most disgusting way is to supervise
their computer habits versus putting
them in jail no senator i didn't say
first that's exactly what you said i
think the best way to deter people from
getting on a computer and viewing
thousands and hundreds and over time
maybe millions the population as a whole
of children being exploited and abused
every time somebody clicks on is to put
their ass in jail not supervise their
computer usage
senator i wasn't talking about um verses
you just said you thought it was a
deterrent to supervise them i don't
think it's a deterrent i think the
deterrent is putting them in jail so the
sentencing have a deterrent component
senator would you let her respond yes
does sentencing have a deterrent
component yes senator deterrence is one
of the purposes of punishment and uh
congress
has directed courts to consider various
means of achieving deterrence one of
them
as you've said is incarceration another
as i tried to mention was
substantial periods of supervision once
the person if i could may ask you in
your view
it's more of a deterrent
to have somebody substantially
supervised in terms of their computer
use who's looking at child pornography
than it is to put them in jail senator
i'm not saying it's more or less exactly
what you're saying what i'd what i'd
like to point out is that if we're going
to
if
let let me say it this way
congress has authorized courts to use a
number of different means
to achieve the purposes of punishment
and one of them is an enhanced
punishment by using a computer
the enhancement with respect to using a
computer relates to
the
penalty in terms of
incarceration and you would choose not
to apply that in these cases you've said
that i'll read you the quote but you've
decided not to apply the use of computer
as an enhancement you've also said
you're not going to hold the number of
images that the person has looked at
as a sentencing enhancement factor is
that true
no senator it's not the number of images
that the person has looked at because we
don't have that information
it is it is the the number of images
that
they've either
received or distributed
you don't we don't know if they looked
at them but you're not going to hold it
against them that they receive 10 000
images versus a hundred
that's not what i've said so well here's
what you said i've decided to apply my
general policy disagreement respect to
those enhancements
at least that is the computers and the
number of images folks what she is
saying the reason she's always below the
recommendation
i think
is because she doesn't use the
enhancements available to her she takes
them off the table and i think that's a
big mistake judge i think that every
federal judge out there should make it
harder for somebody to go on a computer
and view this filth that if you use that
venue which is the venue of choice for
all these child
pornography cases that you use it
against them i think the more you
download like drugs the more you have
the more you go to jail you've made a
conscious decision to disregard those
two enhancement
sentencing factors and i think that is a
wrong way to go in terms of deterrent
to me putting somebody in jail for using
a computer is more of a deterrent than
supervising their activity of watching
the computer that's just a difference
that we have i know i'm out of time and
uh listen i you've lived an incredible
life
but here's one thing that won't happen
to you as we wrap this up
how would you feel
that if i'd had a letter
from somebody accusing you of something
a crime or misconduct
for weeks
and i give it to senator durbin
just before this hearing's over
and not allow you to comment on the
accusation how would you feel about that
senator i'm i'm not sure i don't
understand the context of the question
well let me did you watch the kavanaugh
hearings
no sir are you familiar what happened in
the kavanaugh hearings generally senator
your time is well please mr chairman uh
so to be honest submitted in 47 seconds
she filibustered every question i had
and she has a right to give an answer
but i'm trying to make a point in 20
minutes you were here for kavanaugh if
she's confused about what happened some
people on the other side had an
accusation against judge cavanaugh that
during high school
he sexually assaulted somebody and the
rest is history that was known to the
people on the other side and never
revealed during the meetings they had
with judge cavanaugh it was literally
ambushed he was ambushed how would you
feel if we did that to you
senator i've appreciated the kindness
that each of you has shown me to
see me in your offices to talk with me
about my approach about my question is
what if it's during our 15-minute
exchange it was very pleasant you're
very nice person you have a lot to be
proud of i would never do that to you
if i had some information that sketchy
at best that somehow you've done
something wrong i promise you just from
human decency i would share it with you
i would not disclose it at the last
minute of the last day of the hearing
and i've already given it to a newspaper
so the whole country can read about it
before you ever said a word senator
she's had nothing to do with the clock
no but i'm asking her
about don't even know how
she may feel about what y'all did we
have your time has expired and i'm going
to give her an opportunity to finally
complete an answer so
can't if i could
just answer the question
senator i don't have any comment on what
procedures took place in this body
regarding would you think about the
kavanaugh
what i'd like to answer is your
points about my sentencings in child
pornography cases
the point of the guidelines
is to assist judges
in determining
what punishment to provide in cases and
there are horrible cases but the idea
is that between the range of punishment
that congress has prescribed
judges are supposed to be
providing proportional punishment based
on
what a person has done
the the sentencing scheme doesn't
place everybody at the same level
the the point of judging and the
guidelines is to look at what has
happened in a case
compare defendants to each other in
terms of what they've done and give
proportional
penalties chairman this is non-re she
she has said mr chairman she does not
use sentence enhancements in the area of
somebody using a computer for everybody
can i explain why sir i'm going to give
a witness an opportunity to respond to
you senator finally
at one time
that the guidelines were created for
child pornography
this crime was primarily being
committed
by people who were literally mailing
one two
five ten
a hundred photos at a time how's it
being committed now
would she please go ahead or complete
her answer go ahead
as a result
the commission determined in the
guidelines that it was a substantial
aggravating factor
if the facts of the case demonstrated
that someone had been distributing
hundreds of images because what that
meant was over this long maybe it was a
long period of time
they had collected one photo at a time
they had amassed it they had potentially
mailed one at a time and that showed
really
aggravated
terrible conduct i'm not saying as a
baseline it's not terrible it's all
terrible but what we're doing is we're
differentiating among defendants so in a
world in which the mail is used for the
purpose of distribution it really
matters whether the person has
distributed one or five or a thousand
and so the guideline says you know what
we are going to create a person who's
distributed a thousand a lot worse
because that shows that this person is
really engaged in this really horrible
behavior
in comes the internet
on the internet with one click
you can receive you can distribute
tens of thousands
you can be doing this for 15 minutes and
all of a sudden
you are looking at 30 40 50 years in
prison
good cut good
allow her to finish please i hope you go
to jail for 50 years if you're on the
internet trolling for images of children
and sexual exploitation so you don't
think that's a bad thing i think that's
a horrible that's what the witness said
she should be allowed to answer this
question once and for all senator
senator all i'm trying to explain is
that our sentencing system
the system that congress has created the
system that the sentencing commission
is the steward of is a rational one it's
a system that is designed to help judges
do justice in these terrible
circumstances by eliminating unwarranted
disparities by ensuring that the most
serious defendants get the longest
periods of time and when modes of
commission of the crime change
such that in two seconds
someone can receive or distribute
thousands of images that's no longer
a and this is what the commission found
in their studies an
indicator of a person who
relative to other people has committed
this crime in a more aggravated way
what we're trying to do is be rational
in our
dealing with some of the most horrible
kinds of behavior
this is what our justice system is about
it's about judges making determinations
in medding out penalties
to people who have done terrible things
it is not rational
to take the venue of choice of child
pornographers the computer that have 85
million images on it
and not consider that feeding the beast
we're trying to get people to stop this
crap so when you troll on the internet
you pull down
thousands of images of children from the
internet
i want you to stop that i want people to
go to jail who do that because you're
feeding the beast we have a bill here
the earned act that would allow the
victims who are on the internet over and
over again to sue
the the media companies that provide
these images we have a fundamental
differences of how you deter crime i
think the best way to deter crime when
it comes to child pornography is you
lure the bloom on anybody who goes on
the internet and pulls out these images
for their pleasure
senator every person in all of these
charts and documents
i send to jail
because i know how serious this crime is
every person
i discussed
the harm
of these
terrible terrible images to the victims
who are portrayed in them i talked about
what this crime does to the children who
are being abused in these photos and
on the other side of their terms of
imprisonment i ensured that they were
facing lengthy
periods of supervision and restrictions
on their computer use so they could not
do this sort of thing again
that's what congress has required of
judges and that's what i did in every
case
uh you always were under the
recommendation of the prosecutor many
times the parole people and to be honest
with you judge
a 32 year old man who sent an image of
his own 10 year old daughter you
substantially reduced he got not only
the guidelines but the recommendation
and all i can say is that your view of
how to deter
child pornography
is not my view i think you're doing it
wrong and every judge who does what
you're doing is making it easier for the
children to be exploited if you're on a
computer right now looking at a kid in a
sexually compromising situation and you
get caught i hope nobody gives you a
break because you use the computer
the conduct that's been described is
reprehensible and i think everyone in
this room agrees
and the fact of the matter is that i'm
co-sponsor of your bill the earned act
and i believe that we should be doing
our job here but part of our job we have
failed in responding to the changing
circumstances that face this crime what
has it been 15 or 16 years
she is currently not an outlier in
sentencing 70 percent of the federal
judges face the same dilemma and wonder
why congress has failed to act and when
it will act this is our fault pardon
partially it is senator to be honest
with you it is we have to upgrade these
guidelines and decide whether we're
going to stick with the supreme court
decision that they're not mandatory
senator feinstein thank you very much mr
chairman um i would like to compliment
the witness
you've been answering i think close to
15 hours worth of questions
and i know how difficult this is and
hard it is but i just want you to say in
this senator know that in this senator's
eyes
um you've handled it very very well
so thank you and i'll move on
to my questions
congress has recognized how important it
is for crime victims to participate in
the legal process
and one example is the crime victims
rights act which i authored with senator
john kyle in 2004
that law provides certain rights for
victims at critical stages of the legal
process the right to be notified to be
present to be heard among others and i
understand that in your eight years as a
district court judge you would carefully
consider
victim impact statements when imposing
criminal sentences could you tell us a
little bit about this and how you
considered crime victims in making your
sentencing decisions as a judge
thank you senator um
as you say the law
provides for
victims to have an opportunity to
address the judge to address the court
to explain
the harms that
happen
as a result
of criminal behavior and
in the time that i was
a trial judge
i found it to be a very important part
of our criminal justice process
because
my sentencings
um
were about
handing down consequences for the
behavior that defendants had engaged in
and making sure
that the defendants who received those
consequences understood
that they were getting those
consequences because of the harm that
they had caused
and so what i felt was important for
promoting the purposes of punishment
which is what congress has
required of judges to do
is to ensure that the harms were made
clear to the defendant in every case
so i had for example a case um
a case involving robbery
there were two
uh it was a
single defendant
who committed two robberies one in april
and one in september
of the same small pharmacy
in dupont circle which is not not far
from here it's a small independent
pharmacy
selling uh pharmaceuticals and this
person decided that he was going to rob
the pharmacy of their
um
oxycodone and other kinds of
prescription drugs for sale
that's the sort of standard scenario
that we see in the federal system but
what was so
particularly egregious in this case
is that
this defendant was so bold in his
robberies he came in in april with a gun
he held the employees hostage
essentially forcing him to open the safe
with the drugs in it at gunpoint stole
the drugs
not masked not hiding his identity and
this is pre-covered so we're not talking
about having to have a mask he was a
robber plain and simple with no
fear of people identifying him
and then
in the period between april and
september he would come back to the
pharmacy
he would loiter outside on the street
this is according to the victims they
would see him looking in the window once
or twice he came inside looking like he
was going to buy something and staring
them down and they knew who he was and
they called the police and they weren't
able to uh you know apprehend him
because he hadn't really done anything
at that point
um and the people who worked in the
pharmacy were terrified and they were
terrified by that behavior
uh the menacing nature of it by the time
we get to september he actually comes in
and they think maybe this is another
time when he's just loitering but no he
pulls out a gun he hops over the counter
he assaults one of the uh
people who are working there and steals
the drugs again in that time they were
able to call the police in enough time
for them to come and apprehend him
so at his trial excuse me he did not try
he he didn't go to trial you're the
judge i'm the judge he pled guilty to
this behavior which was well documented
there was no uh defense that it wasn't
him
but the
guidelines in the case and the statutes
that applied
said because he used the gun he was
supposed to get something like seven
years
and i used the victim statements to
first of all explain to him how he had
terrorized the people their statements
said thing one one woman said i can't
work at the pharmacy anymore because i
am so fearful that this guy will come
back it's changed my whole life
it was a whole set of really horrible
circumstances that i read to him at his
sentencing so that he could understand
what he'd actually done and then i
sentenced him above
the requirement
of the law because i thought it was
warranted to make clear to him
that this was a terrible terrible thing
that he had done to these people so the
victim's statements were really
important
because they explained to me and to him
the consequences of his behavior but
beyond just how many drugs he stole or
the fact that he used a gut used a gun
they were the real life circumstances
that resulted from his behavior and it
was important for him to understand that
i i've listened to most all of this
testimony which i think now you've gone
on for over 15 hours and i just want to
say that um
i think you have a stamina
and a very good brain
and a real sense of empathy
has been communicated to me in these 15
hours
and i want you to know that
one of the things that i'm concerned
about
is that the public perception
of the supreme court
has turned increasingly negative over
the last few years
a recent pew research survey found that
44 of adults have an unfavorable view of
the supreme court less than three years
ago that number was 30 percent of adult
adults that held that view
and i understand that as a judge on the
d.c bench you have frequently accepted
invitations to speak at public events in
the hopes of giving the public more
information about the judicial process
and more conf confidence in the outcome
so here's the question
why do you think there's been a decline
in the public's perception
of the court and if you are confirmed
how would you strive to improve the
public's confidence in the court and its
decisions
thank you senator
i i think that public confidence in the
court is very important it is
um
it's crucial to the rule of law
that the public
believe in
the judicial process
um and therefore choose to
accept the rulings of the courts
not just the supreme court but all all
of the courts it's part of the way our
process works
and i think that
i have taken that to mean in terms of my
role as a judge
that
outreach to the public to explain what
it is that we do
um to
inspire
uh hopefully law school students and
high school students um young lawyers in
in law firms and elsewhere
um to
think about careers in the judicial
branch or think about careers in law
as one of the ways that i have attempted
to try to
shore up
public confidence
and
if i'm confirmed i would um plan to
continue
uh as best as i can um
to to to do that kind of thing because
as you say it's very important for
the public
to understand the work of the court and
to follow
follow its pronouncements concerning the
law
earlier you sp when you and i spoke in
my office we discussed some of the
people who have mentored you throughout
your career and one of those was judge
patty serras
you served as a law clerk for her on the
massachusetts district court i believe
early in your career
and you've spoken publicly about the
role she has played as a mentor in your
legal career you have described her as
quote a consensus builder a good
listener a careful speaker the essence
of judicial temperament end quote
so would you share with all of the
members here
more about how judge sarris's approach
to judging and her mentorship have
shaped you and your career
if you give some of the specifics yes i
think everybody would be interested
thank you senator as i reflect on
her mentorship and also the mentorship
of my other two judges it's very
interesting because i think i learned
maybe different things from each of them
judge sarris who was my first
clerkship
you're correct she's
serves on the district court of
massachusetts which is the trial
level court
um
i learned how to
look at the facts in a case
from judge saris
that's part of what
the trial court level does we
as trial judges
develop the record in a case take
testimony have trials
and
she is extraordinary
at
um developing a record and making sure
that all of the relevant facts are
um
deduced from the witnesses and
considered in the context of her trial
uh and and record responsibilities and
so that i i think is something that i
learned from her in terms of the law
and
her warmth and
uh care for her law clerks
meant that she has been a lifelong
mentor to me um and ironically she
became the chair of the sentencing
commission um after i had been on the
sentencing commission so we
worked together
um later in in my career
so i often use that story to tell young
people you know you never know what's
going to happen
someone who you worked for at some point
might be your colleague down the line
well let me just one more
you've handled a large number of cases
during your career both as an advocate
and a judge
as an advocate you've worked on a very
wide variety of cases
from work for corporate clients during
your time in private practice to your
work for low-income clients during your
service as a federal public defender and
during your nine years as a federal
judge you've written nearly 600 opinions
i think that's really quite a sterling
record
and i imagine that some of the cases
have really stuck with you and so i
would like you
if you can
to talk a little bit about some of the
cases maybe one or two
that you've had that have made a deep
impression
and have really
uh enabled you to progress as you have
thank you senator um
well as you say i have handled a lot of
cases uh in my time nearly decade on the
bench and and
you learned something in almost every
case in some respect um if you're doing
your job right and you're looking into
all of the issues
um
i think there might be
i mentioned one
uh from
sort of a few years
into my service as a trial judge i
handled a case
um yaakai versus
napper
and the case involved
trademark infringement and you would
ordinarily think that trademark
infringement
charges are
dry and technical
and and what i learned from this case is
that even
even areas of the law that you might
think
apply only to businesses
impact real people
at times so this case involved a small
community a cultural community
of people who believe in uh vegan
lifestyles um they call themselves the
african hebrew israelites but it's not a
religious community it's a cultural
community around
um a healthy living
and
they have created a restaurant and a
series of restaurants here in the
washington dc area um
uh with menus involving really um
i'm told terrific uh vegan foods and in
this community
there was a
member
who was the one who created the recipes
and who was responsible for the
restaurant the whole community had other
aspects to it
he ended up
falling out with the community and
the dispute involved his actions
essentially taking over the restaurant
and reopening it
by himself
using the same name the restaurant was
called everlasting life which was a
important phrase for
this community
and he essentially ejected the other
members because he was the leaseholder
or he had signed the lease on behalf of
the community
and he kicked him out for a day and then
he reopened the restaurant
using the same name
and so the question was under
the lanham act which is the statute for
trademark violations the question is
whether there is a potential for
confusion
um and in that sort of
circumstance but ordinarily um i see
senator coons nodding ordinarily
when you have a trademark infringement
you're talking about two different
businesses who have very similar
products and the question is you know
are they similar enough to
cause confusion because the idea of the
law is that people should be able to
have products that are identified with
them and and you shouldn't
be confused
and in this case we had a bench trial
about it but it was
pretty clear um i was the fact-finder as
the judge it was pretty clear that when
you
um
open the same build business with the
same name using the same
uh recipes
and food
that you have created this kind of
problem that is a trademark violation um
but what was so interesting to me about
the case in addition to the fact that i
got to be the fact finder it was a bench
trial was that we had witnesses come in
who
testified about
their the circumstances this was a very
small community and they all knew each
other and the
testimony about what it meant to them to
have one of their members ejected in
this way and then have him turn on them
was very very moving in the courtroom so
even though we were talking about this
kind of arcane area of the law it was
real circumstances that were happening
well stop for a minute yes
yeah i i think you're a very important
addition to the court
and what i'm trying to fathom out from
the hearing is what kind of judge will
she be
how will we look at her in five or six
years
and so what i really want to ascertain
is what kind of a judge you will be what
will be the principles you hold dear and
how will you function in this capacity
if you could just answer that one
question i've been waiting for it yes
about 15 hours
i'd appreciate it thank you well i
i would hope to be the kind of judge
that i have been
during this last decade
i have
been the kind of judge who
understands
that
it's my responsibility to rule neutrally
to not
um have any agenda when i'm looking at a
case i've been the kind of judge who
understands that facts matter
facts like the ones that i was just
describing and that it's important for a
judge to
take into account and be able to
understand
the arguments of all of the different
parties and participants
and i've i've been the kind of judge who
takes my responsibility to
not be a policy maker to try to
understand and ascertain the will of
congress if it's a statute or
um
to to to it hew to my
own
um i've been saying stay in my lane um
to
not exert my authority beyond uh the
what the constitution requires when i'm
interpreting and applying the law
i i think i've been the kind of judge
who
lives up to the oath in terms of
being fair and impartial
um ruling without fear or favor
and
um
ruling consistent with with article
three
thank you thank you mr chairman
thank you senator feinstein senator
cornyn
good afternoon judge i understand i'm
the last one maybe before lunch so if
your blood sugar is getting a little low
you can think about
having a little break but um
just because um
the chairman keeps bringing this topic
up let me just ask you uh one
question
when you accuse somebody of a crime
are you
calling them a criminal
oh senator i haven't accused anybody of
a crime
that's not my question when when in
common understanding in plain english
if you
accuse someone of a crime are you
accusing them of being a criminal
i
it depends on the context it depends on
what else you say about them
it depends on the circumstances it
depends on the circumstances yes so you
put this in the same category as
defining what a biological woman is
no i'm you're really not sure
i i didn't say i wasn't sure i said it
depends on this you are sure
no i said it depends on the
circumstances
that that you're positing as to whether
or not you're calling someone a criminal
i just don't think that's credible judge
let me ask you another question you talk
about the um
public confidence
in the courts in our institutions which
i agree are very very important that the
public has confidence in our in our
judiciary
would you agree with me that to the
extent that
people perceive that judges
unelected lifetime tenured judges are
making policy pronouncements or
political decisions that it undermines
public confidence
i do
thank you
yesterday we talked a little bit about
precedent
and i know senator feinstein as she does
uh in these hearings talked about super
precedent and in particular uh roe
versus wade
um
and i want to talk a little bit about
that but first let me just ask you do
you think there's any
good reason
for the supreme court not
to overrule a previous decision when
they've
concluded that that decision was wrong
thank you senator um i again it's hard
for me to answer that question in the
abstract it um
what i'll say is that the supreme court
has laid out factors beyond
just the precedent being wrong as a
reason to overturn it well we talked a
little bit about this yesterday the the
supreme court
revisited the issue of separate but
equal which was the law the
constitutional interpretation of the
supreme court under plessy versus
ferguson
and overruled that precedent because it
concluded it was wrong right
i haven't looked carefully at the
whether all of the different factors
that the supreme court
now uses to overturn were discussed in
the opinion but now the the supreme
court's precedent is to overturn
on the basis of a number of different
factors and not just whether or not it's
wrong
so are you suggesting that the supreme
court
could not or would not overrule a
precedent that it determined was wrongly
decided
no i'm suggesting that
the supreme court's case law indicates
that it looks at multiple factors no i
understand you go through the story
decisis analysis right yes but if it's
wrong that's one of the factors that you
consider right yes but it's not the only
one
so are you suggesting that there may be
circumstances under which the court
determines its previous decision is
wrong but it will not overrule it
the fact that there are multiple factors
indicates that the court looks at more
than whether or not it's wrong okay so
the fact so you would say if i'm
interpreting you correctly that if they
the court concludes its previous
decision is wrong it won't necessarily
overrule that
it applies a
multi-point analysis
yes i think that's okay accurate
back when
roe versus wade was decided in 1973
generally speaking the
the court said that
the states may not limit access to
abortion pre-viability
but
post-viability there could be some
restriction on the right to abortion is
that generally the
as a general matter yes okay thank you
okay
well um
and then i think it's since uh 1973
the question of viability has
risen again what that actually means
because now
viability was around 28 weeks that is
the fetus could live outside the womb
but today
because of the advances in medical
science the fetus can live outside the
womb after about 23 weeks is that your
understanding
senator i haven't studied this so i i
don't know the
the um
a number of weeks in the way that you're
saying
well let's let's talk a little bit about
viability
the line that was drawn
for pre-viability and post-viability
analysis by the courts
what does viability mean when it comes
to an unborn child in your understanding
senator i hesitate to speculate i
don't
i know that it is
a point in time that the court has
identified in terms of
when
the standards that apply to regulation
of the right
justice brennan
at a later point in his career
on the supreme court admitted that
the viability line was an arbitrary
line
do you agree with
agree with him
senator i'm not able to comment on um
viability there's a case pending in the
supreme court right now
concerning the issues
i'm asking you about previous decisions
but i i i hear you
no one suggests that a 20-week old
fetus
can live independently outside the
mother's womb
do they
i i don't know i mean you need
the child will need to be fed or
sheltered and all the other essentials
to sustain human life
so there's no suggestion that after 20
weeks that
a child can be live independently
correct
senator i'm i'm not a
biologist i haven't studied this i don't
know
um
you don't know whether
an unborn child could live outside the
womb at 20 weeks gestation what i know
is that the supreme court has
um
tests and standards that it's applied
when it evaluates regulation of the
right
of a woman to terminate their pregnancy
they have a
the court has announced
um that there is a right
to terminate
up to the point of viability subject to
the
framework in roe and casey and there's a
pending case right now that is
addressing these issues
the constitution doesn't mention the
word abortion correct
that's correct
just like it doesn't mention the word
marriage
correct
that is correct
and um so as you and i discussed uh
perhaps ad nauseum yesterday
when we were talking about substantive
due process this is one of those
unenumerated rights
that the court has
created
court made doctrine or law
in creating a constitutional right even
though it's not explicitly mentioned in
the constitution itself
correct the court has interpreted the
due process clause of the 14th amendment
to increase we talked about substantive
due process yesterday um and that's
that's what this is right the supreme
court
cases that deal with the right of
abortion is a
result of substantive due process
analysis like you and i talked about
yesterday
um yes okay
in the um
you remember when you were confirmed for
the uh court of appeals
uh in that process there was we had a
hearing and then we sent you questions
for the record what we call qfrs around
here yes and uh one of those
uh question number 10
was does the constitution protect rights
that are not expressly enumerated in the
constitution
as part of your answer you said
you mentioned roe versus wade and
planned parenthood versus casey
and you've said this and i'll quote
they articulate a limited right
to terminate
a pregnancy
what
is the limitation
that you understand
that was uh
[Music]
pronounced in roe versus wade and casey
when it comes to a right to terminate an
abortion what are the limitations
under current law
under current law as i understand it um
there are uh
limitations in so far as
there can be
regulation of that right
pre-viability
um
unless regulation
poses
an unburden on the exercise of the right
and there can be regulation
after viability um
as as long as there is exception for the
health
um
the health and i think maybe life of the
mother
um so it's the the limitations are about
whether and to what extent
the government can regulate
the right
is it your understanding under the
current president of the supreme court
that
there is a right to abortion up to and
including the time of delivery of the
child
senator i don't um
i don't
know actually i mean i
the supreme court in every case is
looking at individual
regulations of the government related to
related to individual rights and
um
i am not aware of
the court having
made a pronouncement about
whether or not regulation can come up
can can extend all the way up until
birth i'm just not aware of that
and that it's because the court is
looking at individual cases
and making its rulings in the context of
individual cases and not making
um
sort of pronouncements in general so you
were suggesting that in some individual
case
the right to abortion could extend
through the entire pregnancy up until
the time the
child is delivered
no senator i'm suggesting that i'm not
aware of any case that's handled the
issue
you you told us that you think that you
believe roe versus wade and casey or
precedence and we talked a little bit
about some of the questions about
whether it's a super precedence and the
like
are you familiar with the
supreme court's decision in the heller
case
i am
and that was a decision by the united
states supreme court that uh recognized
the individual right to keep and bear
arms under the second amendment correct
yes
uh is that a precedent of the court
uh it is
and um
you would respect that president
yes senator all presidents of the
supreme court
have to be respected
is it as
is it is
is it equivalent in terms of its
precedence
to roe versus wade or would you evaluate
it differently
i'm not aware of any ranking or grading
of precedence all presidents of the
supreme court are entitled to respect
uh on an equal basis
i i agree with you um that's why it kind
of
blows my mind when people talk about
super precedence as if somehow
one precedent was
different in terms of its significance
or priority and under the constitution
than others
in the short period of time i have
remaining let me just revisit with you
some of the
questions we talked about yesterday with
regarding with regard to a free exercise
of religion
um and of course that's recognized
explicitly under the united states
constitution the first amendment correct
yes okay
are you familiar with the uh
cases
that have been litigated before the
supreme court of the united states
involving the little sisters of the poor
with regard to the
affordable care
mandate on contraception coverage yes
okay
now the little sisters of the poor
benevolent group of nuns i think there
are about 300 of them that take care of
elderly and infirm
individuals and of course as a matter of
their religious beliefs as documented in
the court's opinions uh they don't
believe in
either
contraception or abortion
you agree with that
i believe that was described in the case
that you're talking about i think that's
right yes yeah
and so
when the affordable care act mandated
that every
health insurance policy
contain coverage
for
contraception
or chemically induced abortions
they objected and said that this
violated their conscience and their free
exercise religion
rights under the first amendment right
i believe so yes
well after the
after the obama administration during
the trump administration the trump
administration expanded their
regulations to allow not only
churches but also religious
organizations like the little sisters of
the poor that waver
from that contraception and an abortion
abortion inducing drug mandate
do you recall that yes
have you
are you familiar with the fact that uh
president biden excuse me uh president
biden has said he would restore
uh the previous regulation and
uh that was promulgated under the obama
administration and exclude
um organizations like the little sisters
of the poor from that waiver
potential
for abortion
drugs or contraception coverage
i am not aware of that senator
well i guess what what all this boils
down to you know congress passed a bill
called the religious freedom restoration
act which tried to make sure that
people sincerely held religious beliefs
could be accommodated
under their first amendment rights as
opposed to congress mandating things
that would violate their conscience and
violate their religious beliefs
do you agree with me that it's important
to accommodate
the sincerely held religious beliefs of
all americans when it comes to
legislation that the congress may pass
thank you senator
religious freedom is a core foundational
constitutional right it's
um it's in the first amendment of the
constitution
and uh reflects
the founding fathers um
um
understanding of
uh this country as being one
that is based on
uh in large part the idea of pluralism
the idea that people can come and
have
uh sincerely held religious beliefs and
practice them
uh without persecution that's part of
the foundational
um
foundation foundation of our of our
government and and
the amendment that you're
uh discussing and as a result um
their
that right is protected in in many ways
you mentioned the religious freedom
restoration act
congress has enacted a statute
that when it comes to federal regulation
um
if there's a substantial burden placed
on religion
um then the strict scrutiny
um
standard applies i i agree i have one
minute so i have one more question i
agree with what you just said yes so
since i have
asked this question or made this point
of some of your predecessors who sat in
the same chair
and expressed my
concern about some of the court's
establishment law
establishment jurisprudence
i want to i don't want to leave you out
of that concern
when i was attorney general of texas i
had a chance to argue a case in front of
the united states supreme court and call
it santa fe independent school district
versus
doe
this was a lawsuit brought by the aclu
which sought to enjoin or prevent
a student-led prayer before football
came at the santa fe independent school
district right outside of houston
in the end five judges said that that
violated
the establishment clause of the
constitution causing chief justice
rehnquist to right in his dissent that
the constitution mandates neutrality
toward religion
not hostility but that the court's
decision evidenced hostility
towards religious expression
leaving me to conclude that the public
square we can talk about everything from
violence to misogyny uh to sex you name
it but we can't talk about religious
sincerely held religious beliefs
i would just uh
footnote that for you and plant the seed
for what it's worth thank you very much
thank you thank you senator cornyn
welcome to majority leader schumer glad
you're with us
uh and he would report if he could that
we have a challenge to finish our
hearing today at a time
when we can go to the floor for a series
of votes which will end the day so we
want to stick to the schedule as much as
we possibly can
i will just say that
senator
cornyn's suggestion of lunch was
aspirational
okay
it was an unenumerated right here in
charge of the agenda mr chairman
what we had hoped to do was to take
three more senators before we have an
actual lunch
but it's up to you
is that all right oh whatever you want
to do i i'm i'm
open in here happy to answer whoever
would like to ask me a question thank
you i appreciate that senator whitehouse
thank you chairman
judge jackson you can um
relax for
a bit i
voted for you for the dc circuit and
when you appeared as a
potential nominee we started
doing work looking at your record and
your story
we met with the president to discuss his
uh process and his goals
um
when your nomination was announced we
obviously
brought the work on your record more
into focus and now i've had the chance
over what 15 16 hours
to see your
performance in this hearing which i
think
sets the gold
standard
for patience and courtesy
um
so i'm
prepared to not only support you but to
let you know that i will be
very proud
and very honored and very excited
to support you
um
there are two things that have come up
during the course of the hearing mr
chairman that i'd like to take my time
to have a chance to respond to
and the first has been a question you
know i've been through a bunch of these
now i don't think i've ever heard it
come up so much
questions about the nominee's judicial
philosophy
i didn't know you needed to have one
i actually thought that
when you're dealing with the
constitution
your oath of office
the constitutional precedence
and the constitution itself
kind of gave you your guide path
and when you're construing statutes the
law
and the conventions of the language
and your logic
gave you that path
so the fact that
judge jackson has said i don't have a
digital philosophy
i've got a judicial methodology
doesn't bother me a bit
in fact it kind of bothers me the
expectation that
a nominee to the supreme court should
have a judicial philosophy
because a judicial philosophy
can be a screen
for a predisposition
the judges frankly should not have
but that
folks and powers and interests
influential in the process may very well
want them
to have
so
you know when i think about judicial
philosophy one of them that's come up a
lot has been originalism and one of the
problems with the judicial philosophy is
um
occasional adherence
selective adherence
which
in my mind makes it less of a judicial
philosophy and more of a doctrine of
convenience to be trotted out
when it helps the people that you want
to help
and originalism strikes me as being that
kind of a doctrine and the place where i
think
we have the biggest gap
between philosophy
and practice in all of this
has been with respect to what i've
witnessed
with respect to corporate power in our
democracy in the time
that i have been
in the senate
if you go back to the founding days
there was no expectation that
corporations would have any role in
american democracy nil
doesn't turn up
in the
uh
constitutional debates
doesn't turn up in the
arguments
leading up to the
approval of the constitution
it's
only when corporations became big and
powerful
many decades later
that they began to intrude in our
politics
and they corrupted our politics in a
terrible way history shows
and that led to the movement by
muckrakers
whose probably best leader was teddy
roosevelt
to knock down the grasping political
power of corporations and reign them in
and we had some real victories
at that time
but
ambitions of
those of great wealth and power do not
go away
and they have continually crept forward
um it's an age-old story
and right now
we have corporate power controlling this
congress in a way that is
really remarkable
we have
a complete inability to address
the climate havoc that fossil fuel
emissions are creating
because
half of congress
has been disarmed and disabled
by political influence of the fossil
fuel industry we can't even have a
reasonable and sensible discussion on it
because the power of that industry is so
great
and we've seen that manifested first
with republican justices on the supreme
court letting corporations into politics
that was an interesting invention
and then once they were in they let them
spend money
in politics
and then once they let them spend money
in politics they let them spend
unlimited
money in politics
and now
we are looking at a court whose majority
is in the process of building a right
for
corporations the biggest and most
powerful
corporations that we have to not only
get into politics spend money in
politics and spend unlimited money in
politics but to spend unlimited money
and politics anonymously
to hide from the real voters that we the
people who they actually are
when they're intervening in our politics
and to play this game through phony
front groups with ridiculous names
rhode island is for peace and puppies
and prosperity you know sort of the
quality
of the name that's involved
so
let's not get too excited about judicial
philosophy
if it's nothing more than a screen for a
predisposition that will benefit certain
players
in the arena
and let's certainly not take judicial
philosophy too seriously
when it evaporates
in the face of the interests
that have pushed the philosophy
and i think originalism qualifies that
way and i just wanted to say that i
don't think
you have to have a judicial philosophy i
think you have to have integrity i think
you have to have a judicial temperament
but a philosophy
where has that come from
the second thing i want to say has to do
with the
question of court packing
and the integrity of the court
and i have a
position on this and i just want to say
it so it's all clear and nobody's
reading things into it that i don't
believe and i've had a chance to make my
my point here
and that is the court packing can be
done by adding
new seats to the court
i haven't proposed that i think there's
only one member in the senate that has
proposed that it's gotten a lot of
tension here but i don't think it's been
proposed here
but you can also pack a court by picking
the justices
and in fact there is a long
unpleasant american tradition
of agencies
being taken over by virtue of picking
the members
it's called agency capture
or regulatory capture
it goes back a long way
there is an abundant literature both in
economics and in administrative law
about capture
and there is nothing that makes
a court immune to capture
that is why
when i talked about this in my
initial remarks
i said that the folks that have tried to
capture the court
have treated it no different than a 19th
century railroad commission
because they were legendary for having
been captured by picking the members who
would rule for the railroad
and there are many others go back to mms
in the gulf oil explosion
so that is my concern my concern is that
the picking of the justices
has been handed
to special interests
and we know that's the case because as i
showed yesterday everybody involved
admitted it
the president of the united states said
so
the co-founder of the federalist society
said so
a former chairman of this committee
said so
and the president's legal counsel said
so
and what happened
in that process by which the justices
were picked over at the federal society
we don't know
there was a poll that was taken to
federal society members saying you know
give us your your recommendations
i don't know that there was any meeting
of the board let's take this up let's go
through a proper agenda
what appears to have happened is that
people went into a back room
and there was wheeling and dealing
and millions and millions of dark money
dollars flowed into the federalist
society during this period
and what came out were names
and those went straight to the president
and straight to here
but the picking
appears to have been done
in the confines of a private
organization by anonymous
special interests there is no country in
the world that does that by way of
how you pick judges
if we went to some banana republic to
try to educate them
in democracy
and that was the way they picked their
judges we'd have a lot to say about it
but that is the way
that recent justices have
been picked
court packing
by court picking
and deputizing this to the federal
society is very unusual them having no
process no public process for
implementing that deputization
is very unusual the provenance of these
mysterious lists that were produced and
how people got on and off them
that
is very unusual unprecedented in our
history and it's surrounded by lots and
lots of dark money 400 million dollars i
think is a lot
of anonymous money
that has been chronicled being spent
to control
who gets put on the court
and controlling who gets put
on a governmental body is how you
capture a governmental body and a
captured governmental body
is a wrong
thing
whether it's a railroad commission
or the united states supreme court
there is in that
method of judicial selection not just
the prospect
of impropriety but indeed the likelihood
of impropriety
if it's pay to
play and checks for millions anonymously
delivered will get you into the room to
decide who is going to be on the supreme
court
we got a problem
and that's what happened
and the thing that makes it even worse
in my view is that as you pursue this
and play it out you see the decisions of
the court line up
in an astonishingly clear pattern
with the interests
of big republican dark money donors that
is my concern
that i think is a legitimate concern if
you disagree with me disagree with me
but that is the concern and i wanted to
lay it out here
because it's not about court packing
it's about the integrity of the court
and it's about
the unfortunate
comparison that can be made now
between the captured agencies
delivered through
picking of their membership
and what looks more and more like a
captured court
delivered by the picking of its
membership in secret
with a very very high ticket
price to be in the room where the
picking took place
so
like i said colleagues can agree
colleagues can disagree with we all have
our shots to
make our cases because this has come up
tangentially in multiple different ways
i wanted to take this moment and lay out
what my case is and explain it as
clearly and simply as i can and i thank
the chairman for allowing me that
opportunity and i yield back my
uh remaining seven minutes
and i uh congratulate
your honor you for the patience that
you've shown with all of us it's not
over but it's close
thank you senator thank you senator
whitehouse and of course you've joined
the
hall of fame yielding back seven minutes
senator lee
thank you mr chairman uh thank you judge
i want to talk next a little bit about
a case that you were involved in a case
called coal river mountain watch versus
united states department of the interior
it was decided um
a ruling that you issued in 2015 while
in the federal district court
um i know you've handled a lot of cases
i can't can't imagine that by
merely triggering the uh the case name
that would necessarily bring it back but
this case involved
uh a challenge to
an administrative action within the
department of interior on some issues
bearing on coal mining
uh within the state of west virginia
there were two parallel challenges
brought against that administrative
action one in a federal district court
in west virginia uh where the land in
question was located and another in the
u.s district court for the district of
columbia where you sat
uh
the government defending itself against
that action brought by uh uh some
environmental groups
um
asked that you
dismiss the uh the dc case so that the
matter could be litigated in west
virginia you denied that
can you based on my description of the
facts does that ring any bells and can
you tell me why you might have denied it
thank you senator it actually doesn't it
sounds like um you know dozens of cases
that i handled with similar
um
issues and
requests
something like a motion to dismiss is
early in the action sure and so denying
a motion to dismiss is pretty routine um
i understand and i'm sure you handled a
lot of those um
a lot of those all the time as a
district judge
uh the reason i raise it is just because
it relates indirectly to uh some
concerns that i've got
that are somewhat unique to the western
united states
we have a lot of cases
that
involve the us department of the
interior and agency actions taken
relative to the public land that we have
in every state east of colorado the
federal government owns less than 15
percent of the land in most of those
it's much less than 15 percent in the
single digits were low single digits in
every state colorado and west of
colorado the federal government owns
more than 15 percent of the land and
most of the time it's a lot more in my
state it happens to be about two-thirds
of the land that's owned by the federal
government as a result it complicates
our ability to do just about everything
we do whether it's recreation
construction oil and gas development
whether it's just accessing people's
farms and ranches
or even something is as simple as trying
to fund local
uh fire police search and rescue
operations all these things are affected
by the excessive ownership of federal
land by the federal government and the
way it's often managed sometimes
decisions
made at the federal level are challenged
in parallel actions like these
uh one in the in the forum state in the
host state to where the action is
happening
another in dc and i'm always concerned
about forum shopping
and i'm sure that's something you
watched out for uh as a judge and saw
forum shopping from time to time
it's also something that you know
touches on
an issue that
involves statutory interpretation
there's something called the antiquities
act
passed 110 years ago or so
designed to give presidents of the
united states the authority to designate
federal
parcels of federal land as national
monuments
this text of the statute states that the
limits of the parcels in question
uh should be quote confined to the
smallest area compatible with the proper
care
and management of the objects to be
protected
now given that these uh presidential
proclamations
um uh tend to be broad
um
it's
sometimes um
the objects to be protected are also
broad
and as a result of that
uh it's difficult to tell what the
limits are do you have any reaction as
to how we could discern that how we
could define any meaning out of that
it's got to mean something the text of
the statute you you
you try not to leave language simply
unaddressed or meaningless in a statute
you have any thoughts on how a statute
like that saying that it should be
confined to the smallest area compatible
with the proper care and management of
the objects to be protected any thoughts
briefly on that
um well senator um if i
were presented with a case with that
statute and that circumstance i would
proceed as i always have um you would
have to understand the party's arguments
about
the particulars in the case
what
what is the presidential proclamation
say to what does it
relate
whether there are any precedents in this
area that define
further define or further address what
congress intended with respect to
the statute at issue and i would assume
that it would also matter if the if the
government's lawyers defending the
president's action made an argument that
would leave the uh the interpretation
open-ended meaningless
well as part of your interpretive
exercise
as you're considering
the party's various arguments one that
did not account for all the words in a
statute would be one that you would um
excellent
not
it
you might not agree with no i get it and
this is one of the things that i've
appreciated about what you've told us in
these hearings i i really like uh the
way you've described the effect it's
important to construe
uh the text that you're
asked to interpret and in interpreting
that you look at the language and you're
you're endeavoring to figure out the
original public meaning
and um i i think that is a very helpful
thing
all right
let's uh move to a different issue a
moment ago now you you clerk
on the u.s supreme court for justice
breyer
in october term 1999 is that right that
is right
that was the the same and you court for
justice breyer i did and that was the
same year that the supreme court issued
its decision in a case called stenberg
versus carhart
this is the case where the supreme court
of the united states struck down on
nebraska law prohibiting partial birth
abortion
uh and uh
in the absence of circumstances
uh uh where the baby posed
a threat to the life of a mother
uh
now to be clear that the law prohibited
a procedure where
the abortionist causes an unborn
baby to be partially delivered
by the mother and then the abortionist
intentionally kills the baby outside the
womb by puncturing
its skull with scissors and then
collapsing
the skull uh this is gruesome and i i
don't like having to quote this but the
it is relevant to the topic we're
covering here justice kennedy described
it this way in chilling terms when he
in his descent when he describes the
fact that when scissors are inserted
into the back of the head the fetus's
body wholly outside the woman's body and
alive
reacts as though startled and then goes
limp
justice scalia in his great eloquence um
expressed
lamented the ruling but also expressed
optimism for the fact that future courts
would get it right
saying quote i'm optimistic enough to
believe that one day stenberg versus
carhart will be assigned to its rightful
place in the history of this court's
jurisprudence beside koromatsu and dred
scott this method of killing a human
child
one cannot even accurately say an
entirely unborn human child
prescribed by this statute is so
horrible that the most clinical
description of it evokes a shutter of
revulsion
[Music]
we
then saw a few years later the supreme
court of the united states issue a
different ruling the supreme court uh
issued a different ruling in the case
against
our heart gonzalez v carhart upheld a
different statute this one was federal
rather than state but it was a different
federal stat a federal statute that
also prohibited
uh partial birth abortion
judge jackson can you distinguish these
cases for me what was the difference
between
gonzales v carhart where the partial
birth abortion ban in question
was upheld
whereas in stenberg b carhart
it was invalidated
thank you senator i don't have the
opinions in front of me i think um
i think it
had to do with
the method of extraction the
fact-finding related to um
the procedure
i in one case the district court
um
had made some findings in and the court
felt bound by them and another
uh there
was considerations beyond those that
previously
um relied upon
so there were distinctions that the
court
looked at and considered in the cases
but i'm
yes let's talk about court packing for a
minute yes
one of the reasons court packing
concerns me
one of the many reasons
is because
it's not prohibited in the first
instance it's not prohibited by the
constitution there's nothing in the
constitution that says that congress uh
may not change the size of the supreme
court there's no limitation on that
we have uh for 152 years stuck with the
number nine it has worked
uh in the absence of an argument saying
that that number is two
is too uh uh
low that the court is too small
from a workforce standpoint we need to
expand it it's difficult to imagine uh
why it would be a good idea to change it
particularly because if you increase the
size of the court
in in one fell slow swoop and you you
do that for
partisan political purposes allowing one
president the current president to have
a disproportionate impact on the court
and to change its rulings that that
portion of the court's docket that tends
to be more politically contentious it
can
turn the court into
a political football of sorts given the
the fact that our supreme court justices
uh uh serve for life
um
once you do that
it becomes something of a one-way
ratchet always expanding never
contracting before long you could see an
increasingly larger court with the court
expanding each time a different party
secures the coveted circumstance of a
majority of the house majority in the
senate and controlled by the same party
of the white house
and so this is why it concerns me
i understand that
why it is that
the canons of judicial ethics don't
allow you to comment
on matters that might come before you
this is one that could not come before
you as a justice this is a
non-justiceable political question it's
committed to the two political branches
of government there's not even a
constitutional challenge that could lie
to it even though it's it would
undermine the separation of powers in
the constitution as i see it it's it's
not unconstitutional so it couldn't and
it would never come before you
uh
last night when you were asked a
question by my colleague uh senator
kennedy
on this you acknowledge that you have an
opinion did i understand that right you
have an opinion on court packing senator
i have a lot of opinions i have opinions
on on
i'm a human being and i have an opinion
on a lot of things the reason why um in
my view it
is not appropriate for me to comment is
because of my
fidelity
to the judicial role i understand
that it's a political question and that
is precisely why i think that i am
uncomfortable speaking to it no i i
understand that and i out of respect
respect the impulse i i respect the the
overall um
issue and i think it's it's better for
article three judges and justices
ordinarily to not wade into the
political thicket this one i do think is
different because number one as i say it
can never come before you number two
it does
have an impact on
what you would be doing and you also was
an article three judge
someone who served for nearly nine years
as a federal judge you've developed
experience and intuition and a thorough
understanding of our federal court
system and that's why i think your
perspective on it would be valuable
the reason it concerns me so much is
that even when court packing doesn't
succeed legislatively
it can leave an impact the last time
this was attempted was in 1937 president
franklin d roosevelt was upset at the
supreme court on a number of of bases
he didn't like uh the uh
then 32 year old president of lochner
versus new york where the
five conservatives on the supreme court
engaged in an act of judicial activism
reading something into the constitution
that wasn't really there some people
disagree with me on this but i it wasn't
there
and they imposed that but the bigger
reason was he didn't like the court's
interpretation of the commerce clause
it was that interpretation of the
commerce clause the one we discussed
yesterday you know
prior to 1937
you you had uh
the supreme court agreeing as far as the
channels and instrumentalities of
interstate commerce that we talked about
yesterday he had the court more or less
in agreement over time as to the impact
of the dormant commerce clause but as to
the substantial effects test that didn't
exist yet
it required something much closer to an
interstate commercial transaction
uh in order for commerce
congress's commerce clause authority to
kick in
there were the uh the so-called four
horsemen of the apocalypse
as fdr affectionately called them uh
four conservatives who were consistently
uh pushing uh for limits on congress's
authority and then you had other
justices who would sometimes join with
them usually that included justice owen
roberts who had stood with them in
maintaining
narrower authority
for congress under the commerce clause
all that change went on april 12 1937
two weeks to the day when the
the case often associated with the
so-called switch in time that changed
nine a west coast hotel versus parish
uh or where they undid the lochner
precedent
april 12 1937 the supreme court decided
a case an lrb versus jones and laughlin
steel that forever changed magnified
expanded the commerce clause
in a way that had it been through a
constitutional amendment it would be
among the most significant impactful
constitutional amendments ever adopted
and yet it's rarely discussed
this this case resulted from
one vote one
person on the supreme court who changed
his vote associate justice owen roberts
it's widely believed that i believe it
based on what i've researched on it he
was influenced heavily by fdr's court
packing plan
he didn't want to be on a court that was
packed he didn't want
he he convinced himself that he made
that switch
in order to save the court as
it
was and that has changed everything it's
it's led to a much bigger more expensive
more intruding intrusive federal
government we can disagree
as to the policy merits of that but it
did change the constitution that's why i
worry about that so i i hope i
understand you don't want to answer i
hope that uh between now and the end of
the day you'll see fit to tell us what
your opinion is i do think it's it's
worth worth discussing
let's talk for a minute uh
got just a moments
left i want to get back to your
your sentencing approach
now
when you approach these child
pornography cases
what you're describing
uh in many circumstances is an overall
concern that you've got with the
sentencing guidelines and particularly
that portion of the sentencing
guidelines
uh that deals with child pornography
cases this showed up in the
um in the
transcripts of some of your sentencing
hearings including the
the transcript of your sentencing
hearing in the in the hawkins case
i turned to that uh to page 38
uh lines 17 to 24 of that transcript and
here's something you say in that hawkins
case uh and i believe this was the 18
year old defendant that you sentenced to
to three months in prison when the
lower end of the guidelines range would
have been 97 i think the higher end
would have been in the 120s or something
like that you said and in your case this
is you speaking to mr hawkins in your
case in particular i don't feel that it
is appropriate
necessarily to increase the penalty on
the basis of your use of a computer
or the number of images
or prepubescent victims as the
guidelines require because these
circumstances exist in many cases
if not most
and don't signal an especially heinous
or egregious child pornography offense
i've got a couple of questions about
that where those
you start off that paragraph sounding
like you're you're making a
determination as to him but then the
observations you make in that paragraph
seem to apply
broadly is that is that right
so what
senator um
i don't have the transcript of mr
hawkins case i recall
that i found that case
um like all child pornography cases
to be
difficult really difficult
and his case
i recall
was
you